well welcome to division one um first on
our agenda we have House Bill
318 relative to bail Commissioners and
making an appropriation to the judicial
branch this came out of Criminal Justice
with a vote of 20 to zero and then
passed on the house floor on a Voice
vote back on the 3 of January
so someone like to speak to the bill
anybody here that I believe
represented
the good representative from Salem how
are
you great thank you
um I'm here primarily as a resource
because I've been a bail commissioner
for 23 years and uh the reason this was
20 to nothing and I was one of them is
because this was a
truly this was really a truly bipartisan
effort and I did not want to honestly
spoil the party there are some issues I
have with it but I'm not I want to avoid
policy the house has spoken and I don't
want to
uh talk about that especially Financial
impact though is something that I ask
the committee to think about and that's
this a system of magistrates was set up
and if you read the bill it's not very
carefully defined their responsibilities
how they interact just what they're
really doing
um the the system as
it uh works now can be fine-tuned
education requirements perhaps
guaranteeing increasing bail
Commissioners fees in order to attract
more perhaps um
uh
um uh getting the state to guarantee
some of the payments uh for some bail
Commissioners who really don't get right
around Rockingham County and don't get
paid very as often as they should should
uh but that's I'm wandering into policy
the part that really is costly is the B
the uh magistrates I think should that
needs real work more study just what is
their role what are they going to be
doing at a time when money may very well
be
uh may have unexpected draws on it I'm
not sure that that's warranted the only
tiny bit of policy I might mention is I
don't think we thought about this in
committee we're education requirements
are a wonderful idea I wholeheartedly
support that 16 hours for new bail
Commissioners and that's how I train
mine they came to me with be 2 amm and P
to Pelham to see what it's like to see
DUIs at that hour of the night morning
uh is but for established mail
Commissioners I think it should be not
eight hours but up to eight hours and
the court to decide how that agenda
should be filled because I don't like
there's nothing magic about that number
it's a reasonable number but uh I don't
want to
see make work I want whatever time we
spend to be real time not
uh well we're going to count lunch as
part of our uh training anyway that's
apart from those comments I'm here if
there are any questions about what
day-to-day life is for a bail
commissioner as it reflects on this bill
and thank you for thank you for
listening oh don't run away
representative scitech representative
question yeah so uh just to about policy
receive in finance so our job is to make
sure we get value for money right so we
have to know what something does and and
how valuable it is to the state and
compare it to all the other you know
requests we get for money so we do
sometimes have to delve into policy and
figure that those kind of things out
um so as I understand it um the way
things work is that um someone gets
arrested and and when it's a serious
when it's not serious if it's speeding
or something they just get a a a summons
on the road and they go but if it's
something more serious um domestic
violence or uh DUI or something like
that they get brought to the police
station and the police call a bail
commissioner and the bail commissioner
comes and interviews the person and
decides whether or not uh that person
can be safely released um on bail is
that correct there's one element I would
add to that okay and that's a hand a
hand summons or often called a must
appear uh does not impose bail
conditions and very often there are bail
conditions that the police want you may
not go back to that store you must avoid
contact with this particular person uh
that's sort of the you must abstain from
alcohol until you see the judge that
that for a DUI for these are uh one of
the other issues that you I would like
to add to the list of things you said so
those are conditions imposed by the bail
commissioner that's correct okay and
since since I represent the Judiciary
not the
police the police can't add conditions
that's right okay so and furthermore the
money part of it is that for the bail
commissioner service they're owed $40 by
the by the accused right that's correct
yeah and so because of that sometimes
the accused doesn't have the $4 and so
sometimes the bail Commissioners get
stiffed that's true and uh that's been a
perennial complaint about bail
commissions it ranges from this is just
out of the Hat Manchester is five out of
10 10 don't get paid and Manchester has
I have gone from Salem to Manchester to
take them for the to take one for the
team because I believe in what I'm doing
and it's no fun to ride from Salem to
Manchester in the early hours of the
morning to bail somebody for nothing I I
but I signed up for it and I'm not not
I'm not not going to do it I'm from my
point of view Salem my area does fairly
well in terms of getting compensated for
the service but I know others from talk
within Rockingham County I don't believe
it'd be different in other counties
people do a lot of riding around and
they're losing three4 out of 10 and
that's that's just it's hard to retain
it's hard to feel good about what you're
doing right and so this bill has the
Judiciary pay the the money and then the
Judiciary very later when the when the
accused comes to court we'll collect the
money from them is that that's the
that's what the bill theoretically says
but something that I I I don't know I I
don't know I want to be careful of my
tone here in all of our hearings on this
rather important bill the Judiciary was
not present they did not have anything
to say with respect to either policy or
mechanics of this bill now maybe they
were watching this on stream but I found
it uncomfortable that we're doing this
without any input now perhaps they're
saying they don't want it I think I see
a representative of the Judiciary here
so well okay they W they weren't they
were pretty invisible at the I
understand criminal
protction
and okay I understand so but one last
thing so um
as I understand it the total number of
bail Commissioners is 95 and some of
them aren't very active necessarily and
so this bill also adds
magistrates to kind of like be hired
bail Commissioners and some sense right
to work weekends and and stuff like that
um but it seems to me those 15 employees
would have a hard time going to police
there's enough of them to go to police
stations and do what bail Commissioners
do how how would that work in my view I
think the that's a low number
for uh so that I'm a little worried
about what the fiscal note says here I
think that's both a low number and the
what's more of a concern is their role
is not exactly defined in the bill there
there's it talks about it sets it up but
I'm not sure what they're going to do
that bail Commissioners aren't already
doing and if it's to save a judge a call
on a Saturday that's just too bad excuse
me okay thank
you Melissa Mike do we have an updated
thanks uh representative scitec I served
as a bail commissioner under judge
Crocker lazat and dresser down the
Milford District as it was called at the
time now it's of course a circuit and we
never had any trouble getting paid
because we would Circ on the bottom of
the form that we weren't paid or we were
paid and when the U defense defendant
came before a judge if uh we hadn't been
paid the judge would make sure that
payment was issued as part of his
conditions or her conditions because
judge Crocker is a woman but is there a
reason that isn't done so Bill
Commissioners don't rack up all this
expense or were the judges just doing
that out of the goodness of their heart
so we got paid how long ago were you a
bail commissioner about 15 years ago
well all right uh that's the theory
uh we do ask for it and occasionally it
comes through but it's very
occasionally
okay uh other further questions
representative wer thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative scitec so you
show up and who set the bail is that
bail not set until they're in court no I
set the bail the bail commissioner sets
the bail
normally if we have no if we don't if
the subject reste is not judged to be a
Flight Risk uh then we'll just set
personal recognizance look for bail
conditions and verify that the police
recommendation we usually operate on the
police recommendation we will interview
uh when but normally this it's fairly
cut and dried uh we ask for cash now if
I've got somebody from Dorchester
Massachusetts that's doing drug that's
we
that they have been after this person
for some time it's either a very high
cash bail if he's not actually held if
this is I'm talking about a seller of
drugs dealer I I know somebody that got
a phone call from a a nephew that you
need to come and bring cash and had to
bring a couple thousand dollars that and
the bail commissioner wouldn't sign
anything until somebody had put some
actual cash down is that so that's not
that that's I don't know that that's
rare I mean it
I
when once every six months I do
something like that that's exceedingly
rare uh that you actually I'm holding
you because and I know Uncle Louis is
going to come up with the money it has
happened but it's extremely I'm talking
once every six months I said so when you
bail them it's mainly personal recog you
don't actually see any cash most of the
time yeah yeah you might see the $40
they're e they're either held or
released it's rare it's become
increasingly unusual to ask for cash
thank
you now there is a representative from
the judicial branch here we'd like to
hear your comment since as
representative scitec said there was no
judicial communication during the
process of the bill going through
criminal
justice hello I'm Erin krian I'm the
general counsel for the judicial branch
uh we we did get a chance to see these
drafts while they were in process I I
don't believe we offered testimony uh
but we did get a chance to review them
before there were committee votes I
think there was maybe one or two that
were the subject of U intense
negotiation right up to the vote and
there were some Maybe changes from the
last time we had seen it but we did get
drafts nothing else to add are you in
favor of the bill or the judicial branch
in favor of the bill or well we we try
to refrain from taking a position
because given the position that we have
going last and applying the law we don't
want to step into your role which is
making policy decisions um we do
appreciate that we got the opportunity
to weigh in on what we could Implement
uh you know there are sometimes in a
policy Vision implementation challenges
um and we appreciate that we got the
opportunity to talk about what would be
more or less challenging for us to
implement um there are costs associated
with making some of these changes that
you it does represent a bold policy
Vision that would change some of the
things we currently do uh but I I as I
say we do appreciate that we were able
to give feedback on whether we could
implement it or not I was just glancing
through the new fiscal note I noticed
the judicial brand
has an estimate of about $848,000 of pay
the bail
Commissioners is that something you
propose a take out of your present
budget or a new appropriation it's
currently in statute that we have the
ability to pay the bail Commissioners
but it hasn't been appropriated for a
very long time um so we do periodically
get the question of how much would it be
if we were going to pay them and and
that's the number that um judge king
from the circuit court and formerly
judge Neto from the Superior Court had
come up with as is sort of a stable
year-to-year good estimate of how much
that would cost uh so it's it's
something that we are happy to do we
just currently don't have it
appropriated from the legislature to do
okay thanks questions uh representative
Maguire thank you yeah I think wouldn't
it be fair to say most of that would be
reimbursed by the accused I I think it
depends uh and I think representative
scitech is right that there are courts
where the the the number of indigent
defendants is very high and so some of
the bail Commissioners that in those
courts in particular that those that
have our highest quit rates of of bail
Commissioners because they're just not
being compensated frequently enough uh
so I think that it's maybe more than
half you'd recover but I I don't would
not guess that it would be
full and I had a zoom with u Miss krian
and um judge Howard who's Judge NATO's
replacement at the head of the superior
court and um uh Miss uh Goram who's the
uh head administrator for the courts and
they all seem to like this particular
part of the bill they the the part
relating to bail Commissioners that they
thought that was very workable and would
improve the situation of bail
Commissioners it is it is certainly a
change that would be easy to implement
and it's something many of the bail
Commissioners they have asked us to do
uh we just were not appropriated to do
it um there was a a case Fallen be that
was decided while uh Kelly aot was
governor that um it could not be
required repayment of an Indigent
defendant or it would violate one of our
constitutional Provisions so I think
that may have there may have been more
stable recovery in the past before that
case was decided and then it was not
appropriation so you've already got
Kelly aot as a governor I I can't
remember Senator Governor attorney
general lot of hats a woman of many
talents but at the time she was attorney
general excuse me she no problem I think
I've I've now seen the sign that says
Kelly Governor enough that I say it
without thinking about it my apologies
oh not a problem further questions
representative Sweeney do you have any
no grassy Griffin
wer represent
eil I mean I'm just not that familiar
with this uh this system but did many of
the numbers that are in the fiscal notes
come from the judicial branch yes ma'am
so we did a we did a comparison to one
of our labor grades that we would be the
one that a magistrate would come from
and that's where the estimate of the
cost of 15 magistrates comes from our
estimate of the bail commissioner fees
is based on our recurring count of about
how often bail Commissioners are
appearing although it is not always uh
very well tracked but we tracked it over
a few years and we think that that's an
accurate estimate uh we don't have a lot
of information about electronic
monitoring because it's not something we
currently do so we were not able to give
a projection there but the the numbers
that we've given were ones that came
from us
internally
follow up and did you have input on the
number of magistrates that were included
in the bill my understanding is that
that number comes from a previous bill
from the last session where and forgive
me I do not know who the prime sponsor
was um proposed eliminating the bail
commissioner system and replacing them
entirely with magistrates and that was
the estimate that we had of how many
magistrates it would take to cover the
state at that time uh it it Bears
mentioning that the number of Bill
Commissioners has been declining over
time for a relatively long period of
time we were stable at around 200 uh
before Co that had dropped to about 130
and now that's down to 95 and partially
this is that repayment becomes an issue
and so you have fewer people
volunteering uh so I my understanding
and I don't want to speak for the the
policy authors of the bill is that that
there may be a sort of gradual loss of
Bill Commissioners and ultimately a
supplantation with uh bill with
magistrates over time just type one more
more so I think you said that you did
have input on the
bill um because you wanted to make sure
that it was something that you could
Implement
so in the current version of the bill is
this something that the branch is
comfortable with from an implementation
standpoint aside from the finances are
there things that you don't think quite
work uh I think overall we with the
right resources we can implement the
only thing that I think and I and I
appreciate that the authors of the bill
considered this is that unlike some
other states New Hampshire does not have
a pre-trial division within the courts
so if you go to mass or you go to the
federal system there is judicial branch
staff which uh is probation officers
parole officers monitoring people on
electronic monitoring we we just don't
have that in in New Hampshire it's done
by the counties um so I think that and
it's not done consistently some of the
counties do it and some don't and I
think that the authors of the bill
wanted to make that more common and so
they gave the judicial Branch the option
of doing it ourselves which would
require having some sort of pre-trial
division or Contracting or using private
services or Contracting with another
another government agency uh I
appreciate that they gave us that
flexibility but um I think there that we
would have to figure out how to
implement it and I think the most likely
way would be to use the option that
they've given us to contract with
another government agency such as the
counties that do do electronic
monitoring so I think they envisioned
some flexibility there which we
appreciate um but that' probably be the
most challenging for just because we
area representative
Griffin thank you Mr
chair um it seems to me that adding 15
magistrates is a type thing that should
happen on the budget
year uh I know this this came up
recently in this bill but it would seem
to me that this is uh particularly with
the amount of money involved and the
time of year that this is something that
would more properly be on your budget
and I wonder what your thoughts are
around that uh I I I would have to defer
to the legislature's judgment on that I
I understand that it there are much
fewer resources available to to allocate
year any further question
thanks
see sweee thank you mrman thank you for
being here so I just want to clarify so
the 15 magistrate number was from a bill
in which there were no bail
Commissioners it was a fiscal note that
we completed for a bill to completely
replace bail Commissioners with
magistrates and the 15 was the number
needed to replace okay that's correct
thank
you seeing no further questions thank
you chairman Roy I saw
you sitting back there watching this
very
you um I didn't catch the all of
Representative sitec uh testimony I I
would just um I would caution that he's
one bail commissioner in one area we
heard hundreds of hours of testimony
from bail Commissioners across the state
from jails across the state from um
anyone from courts across the state we
heard from everyone so his
representations reflect his experience
and not that of the whole state
um with regards to the question on the
15 bail Commissioners that number was
from the original Bill however when we
looked at the the need for the bail
Commissioners we needed one for every
County so and we needed one to cover in
the counties when there was need for
vacations Etc and we were tasking them
with managing the bail Commissioners so
the number actually just worked out
would to be the same if the committee
for fiscal reasons decides to pair it
down I would only ask that you remember
we need them for every
County um with regard to the need for
them at all or whether we should wait
for a a budget year I would ask the
committee to remember this bill started
last year in the
Senate and came from three or four
different bills that came to us from the
house this is an urgent matter the towns
across the the state the cities are all
demanding some kind of reform with our
bail
situation so we decided to take a
holistic look at it the reason the
magistrates are needed is because the
Senate wants to and we concur with some
very serious crimes not allow bail
Commissioners to make those decisions
they want a higher person they wanted
judges at first to do it and then the
courts just didn't have the staff to do
that it wasn't a matter well too bad
make him work on a Saturday it's a
matter of just there's no bandwidth to
do it um also back to the training and
supervision of the bail Commissioners no
one's able to do that we heard that it's
not happening um so it's really tough
with just envisioning bail Commissioners
carrying out the law the way that we
want and the way that the Senate wanted
um so you'll see in the bill there's a
list of crimes that a bail commissioner
can't decide on that's where the
magistrate comes in the magistrates work
all the weekend they work all the time
to cover for those certain crimes if we
were to take those out the whole bill
falls
apart um because then you end up with
these crimes and those people will be
end up being held at least 36 hours and
perhaps longer versus only 24 hours
until they can see someone a decision be
made so this bill was carefully crafted
so that all the stakeholders agreed did
anyone think it was perfect no but
that's the only way you get everyone to
agree
um I feel like we spent hundreds of
hours on this so to to kind of start
pulling the strings apart is the whole
thing will end up falling apart if
there's fiscal matters that need to be
shaved off the edges that I can
understand but if we're going to start
picking at the policy toci well do we
need this do we need that please
remember we spent an enormous amount of
time talking to so many people to get
this just what it needed to be so I
would take
questions uh thank you I just like to
add when I was looking at the docket the
other day I saw that your committee
alone met I don't know countless times
yeah hundreds of hours yeah represent
Maguire thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question
so um how do you see the magistrates
working are they going to travel to the
police stations and deal with these
cases or are they going to do it over
Zoom or phone or something like that or
we didn't want to micromanage the court
on how they did that some cases they may
have to travel just out of uh necessity
because there's nowhere to do a zoom
type of situation sometimes they may be
able to do that um it it's really up to
the discretion of the courts so that the
person gets their due Pro their due
process rights um so if doing it over
Zoom allows that great if it doesn't
then they're going to have to go in
person so I can't I wouldn't be able to
tell you in all honesty how it will work
exactly each case it'll be dependent on
the case in in my opinion keeping in
mind they're going to have to travel
most of the time I think because to get
the record the person's criminal record
they actually have to get it in their
hand because you can't transmit it
legally over facts or something like
that so it's it's very complicated as
far as looking at that person's criminal
history record and unless they're in a
place where they can pull it themselves
they'll have to
go if they're at home for example they
can't get a criminal record so they're
going to have to have to go at least to
a
courthouse I see um can I may yeah so I
know that uh the J the Judiciary told me
that when a bail commissioner is not
available there are a handful of bail
Commissioners who do their work over the
phone right and so if they're not in
person it seems to me that's not as good
right I mean a bail commissioner in
person wouldn't that be superior to a
magistrate over the phone or over Zoom
or something like I would say that they
would work the same um so if a if a
magistrate if a commissioner can do it
over the phone so can a magistrate if
they don't they can't again that's up to
the court if it was up to me I'd say
absolutely they should all go every time
but I I really can't tell them how to
how to run their business I can just
tell them this is the policy want you we
want you to enforce okay um but yeah
absolutely it be better a person but to
your point of well would it be better
with a just bail Commissioners because
because they can go so can the
magistrate and remember we're only
talking about a limited number of crimes
that the bail Commissioners wouldn't be
handling anyway it's the most serious
crimes that those magistrates and the
magistrates have to work all weekend um
and we heard testimony from many people
from the jails where people sat
sometimes for a couple days because the
bail commissioner just didn't show up
there wasn't any they called all the
ones they had and that was it so it's
not like there's one person that they
can always call and they'll be on Zoom
one more thank you so I spoke to uh
judge Howard specifically about this
question
of is there any sense that the bail
Commissioners are making poor decisions
about who should be bailed and who
shouldn't and so on and he said no he
said he didn't think you know he said
maybe some more training would be useful
but but there isn't there there isn't
seemingly a crying need uh for a
professional to do something that the
bail Commissioners do now um did you
hear other cases are there sort of
horror stories about this bail
commissioner did something wrong and Etc
yeah actually there were um we heard one
uh a very recent case where someone was
arrested for um for let me see he he
beat up his wife um I believe he
urinated on her uh she was horrifically
beaten up and the bail commissioner let
him go on personal recognizance I mean
it's just it's there needs to be a
higher level and I understand um I
understand the policy issue of the judge
but keep in mind this bill doesn't just
handle the judicial system it handles
Criminal Justice System all these other
players are involved so the judge might
not be in favor of it but it's not the
Court's bill it's the it's the whole
systems bill um and they didn't seem to
voice that concern when we talked to
them and I met with the Chief Justice
judges any further questions for the
chair uh yes represent you will thank
you for coming and really thank you so
much for all the work that you and the
Committees it's just phenomenal um so
from the magistrate standpoint you said
that you know we could consider shaving
here and there you think at a bare
minimum there should be at least one
magistrate Per County yes and if if if
it gets to one magistrate Per County and
there's a magistrate IM medication a
judge is just going to have to pick up
the slack um because the law will still
stipulate that the people that are
arrested for these crimes have to be
seen by a judge or or a magistrate so I
I would say the bare minimum would be
and if you decide in your wisdom that
that's the the financial best financial
way to go and they need more they can
come back and ask for them in the budget
year and their appropriation um but as
far as the the emergent nature of this
bill I would say the the 10 one per
County would be good well just follow I
I remember when you were here before you
said that um the 15 number was an
attempt to have backup for magistrates
who were not um available yes and and
again I want to emphasize um there the
magistrates are are are available to the
courts for more than just what's in this
bill they're available to the courts to
carry Min ministerial hearings that will
free up judges there are certain
hearings that a magistrate can conduct
um in the courthouse that will free the
judge to do other things on the docket
so they're they're multifaceted we're
not just hiring people to to work a
couple hours on a Saturday night they
are going to be full-time employees of
the court and they plan to put them into
into use can miss one more question sure
do you do you feel that the decrease in
the number of bail Commissioners has to
do with the amount of compensation they
getting I think it's it's multifold I
think it's um number one the the lack of
any compensation that many of them get a
large percentage it's the amount of
money um we don't give them any any gas
mileage any anything they just get this
fee and some of them drive a long way
and the gas prices as we know have gone
through the roof so we we talked about
well should we put in a mileage and it
became complicated and hard to manage so
we said well you know what let's just
bump the bump the I think we bumped at
$10 or to 50 and that should help them
with the increase in gas um so as long
as they're getting paid every time I
think that will help another complaint
we heard is unresponsiveness from the
courts um no training the training that
they got was you know sometimes you got
it sometimes you didn't it sometimes it
was great sometimes it wasn't it wasn't
very very standardized um so that was
their number one complaint was training
and feeling like they weren't just out
there in a kind of in the wild
west thank you and they were they were
getting when anything goes wrong all
fingers pointed at them and they're like
well we can only do what you give us to
do and tell us to
do representative McGuire has one more
question sure absolutely so on numbers I
have in mind that that there are 5,000
arrests in New Hampshire
a year that require a bail commissioner
I don't know if that's correct or nor do
I but we can go with that all right do
you know how many are in this um these
crimes that are being
excluded uh that would require a judge
or
magistrate I'll be honest we did at one
point I I don't have that number in my
head anymore if if you're taking a vote
today I can't help you but if if you if
you have some time I could pull that
number thank um but we did have Miss Gan
knows the answer she may but I hate to
put her on a spot
um do you do believe the new um crimes
were it it was around 6,000 based on
2021 numbers but that was a high pror
year so it could be a little bit lower
and how many are do you know that
there's a list of serious crimes that
that's that's the list of all cases
brought that were those serious crimes
we do not have a good number of how many
cases involved a bill commissioner
because we don't want to track that
specifically but 6,000 is all uh is the
number of initiated cases involving one
of the enumerated crimes so 6,000 isn't
the total arrest in Hampshire it's the
number of those those crimes these
crimes that are being excluded from bail
commission
yes that that seems like way too many no
look at the crimes all right I mean
every one of them's a a serious um
bodily injury felony um
and and again that's that's a policy
compromise with the Senate the Senate
wanted um the felony version I mean the
misdemeanor versions of those crimes we
should no only the felony versions so
it's we compromised already on that
number all right thank you
yeah other
questions sing thank you thank you
chairman thank you members of the
committee
are there any further questions uh
concerning House Bill
318 seeing none will at least close the
work session for now as far as accepting
any more testimony but representative
Maguire I believe has an amendment that
bill so chairman Roy you might want to
there
once everybody gets a copy we'll have
Amendment
um so what I asked for and I hope I
got is
yeah
see make certain changes yeah so what I
asked for is I it seemed to me that that
the
magistrates is to is intended to be a
kind of hired bail commissioner right
somebody who's working for the state but
doing the same function as the bail
commissioner and of the people that I
spoke to none said the bail
Commissioners are doing a bad job they
all said we don't have enough of them
right and so the key to me the key part
of the bill was let's pay them more and
make sure they get paid right so pay
them the
$50 and get them paid from the Judiciary
not the um uh not you know willy-nilly
from the from the defendant and then
secondly
um secondly
uh get them the training part right keep
the training part to get them a little
better trained and so hopefully those
changes would get the the decline in
bail Commissioners to be an
increase um and and so we could see how
that works right uh prior to hiring the
magistrates right so um so let's not do
everything all at once here but let's
try can we strengthen the the bail
commissioner system first and then if
that doesn't
work um we can talk about the
magistrates later but it just seems to
me that the that the magistrate idea
isn't all that workable because the work
of the commissioner of the bail
Commissioners is in the police station
right they have to travel they have to
go to the police station they need to
meet the people and so
you know one for Hillsboro County you
know two for Hillsboro County I mean how
is that going to work so so you know I I
appreciate um chairman Roy's position
but it just seems to me we need more
Commissioners to start with and and not
and and let's slow down on the big
spending item which is the magistrate so
that's what I asked for I I'm reading
and and maybe we should wait until we
see more of those specific numbers
because I I I can't believe there's
6,000 that would be a 100 a week of
these serious serious crimes right I
mean that doesn't make sense right
data our share of
what yeah
right anyway uh um we won't act on this
today so anyone out there that had some
heartburn um we won't act on this today
we have a few weeks ahead of us and so
we won't make a decision and I I believe
representative Maguire may need some
additional numbers yes to support his
Amendment so let's do that that's a good
ide that being said everyone okay with
that all right so thanks for attending
uh nice to see chairman Roy and
representative scitec
all right uh we right on time yeah
pretty
close so the next uh Bill we have is
House Bill
training yes Mr chairman would you like
to take a seat I am pinch hitting all
thank you Mr chairman and members of
Finance I chair the special committee on
the Family Division of Circuit Court of
which representative katab the prime
sponsor was a most valuable member and
chaired the subcommittee on judicial
training I'm pinch hitting at the last
minute because she's tied up in
judiciary where she is the clerk we had
14 hours of testimony from the public
most members of which complained about
the process of how their family court
trials were conducted and turned out and
we sifted through a lot of that to find
some actionable information and came up
with several things that we thought uh
would be good changes in the uh judicial
system as the chairman of this from the
beginning I took the attitude I wanted
the Judiciary and this special committee
to gang up together against problems and
not gang up against each other which too
often
happens the special committee concluded
that one of the areas the process could
be improved is in having greater
training initial and ongoing for
judges uh conversations both in
committee and privately especially
privately indicated that some of the
judges believed this would be a good
idea to give you a hypothetical a judge
assigned to the family court
retires the governor nominates to the
executive Council a wonderful lawyer
renowned for diligence and
integrity the problem is all of her
legal career she has been a patent
attorney and as of next Monday she's
going to be in family court and while
she is a quick study and does her
homework um you can finish that thought
she's never had a divorce or child
custody case either personally or
professionally she's never appeared
before the Family Division of the
Circuit Court as a lawyer or a litigant
or a person
involved so our special committee came
to believe a greater amount of initial
and continuing education would be in
order one might raise the question that
the word shall is used in an instance
most of the time it says may in other
words we're saying this would be a good
idea we think but there is the question
of uh we are the legislature and they
are the Judiciary and there's certain
things they don't do in our playground
and vice
versa retired chief justice Bob Linn
presently chairman of the Judiciary said
that he saw no problem where the word
shell was used that it would be a
constitutional issue so this is just to
make our judges better trained initially
and given more continuing education
along the
way so just a little history for the
division uh this passed out of the
Judiciary Committee 18 to1 and on the
house floor on the February 1st it was a
Voice vote to pass so
questions you must have done a good job
well it's a good team it's a great
committee thank you uh thank you
Judiciary certainly thank you again for
the record Aon crean general counsel for
the judicial branch um we appreciated
the opportunity to work with the special
committee on the Family Division um a
lot of very interested perceptive and in
a deep dive on what was going on in
Family Court we had legislators come and
and sit through entire days uh of of the
Court's docket and I think they they
came to appreciate a lot and they had
some very perceptive
observations uh I think the the
suggestion to have a Judicial training
coordinator is one of those very
perceptive observations for for the
judicial branch this is a collateral
Duty for many of the people who engage
in training uh there's potentially a
cost-saving to having a person go and
find free trainers which many people are
potentially willing to do but right now
if someone's doing that as just a side
duty of their job they they're not
necessarily able to give the same amount
of time and resource to it um I think
the suggestion is an excellent one we
nowh it's a suggestion being made
outside of the budget cycle um if for
some reason it was not brought forward
now we would bring that suggestion again
because it is a very good one uh and we
would absolutely use this resource um so
so we appreciate that suggestion um I I
put myself in Peril in the Judiciary
Committee disagreeing with former Chief
Justice and chairman of the house
Judiciary Committee Bob Lynn who's in
addition to those things a very good
lawyer um that there is a substantial
amount of case law that currently exists
that does suggest that having the
mandatory sh would be unconstitutional I
understand that he has a a different
perception of that but the way that this
typically comes up is if someone Sues
and that turns out to be correct we're
not going to be able to enforce the law
if it's changed to a May and someone
sues the independent action of the
Judiciary will be enough to save the
suggestion so this happened for example
in Senate Bill 130 from the last session
they put in a May instead of a sha so
that the Chief Justice could execute on
the legislature's suggestion and there
would not be a li challenge that would
be successful that their requirement was
unconstitutional uh that's the way it
typically comes up is a third party
brings a suit and then we're not able to
um enforce the legislator's suggestion
so I I did not raise that issue to to
challenge the legislator's power which
is vast when it comes to judicial
matters but to just to insulate um the
policy suggestion from a
lawsuit would you take questions of
course representative Maguire yeah this
is more in the nature of a statement but
I I agree with you as part this shet
stuff and that you know we shouldn't
interfere with the judges um internal
stuff but I really wish the Judiciary
would give us the same courtesy and not
interfere with
our prerogatives right which they do all
the time so I I have an amendment on
this
bill well the amendment is being passed
out representative evil has a
question um so do you think that the
initial training for judges let me put
it the other way do you think the
continuing education for judges is as
important a piece as the initial
training yes ma'am I
do and do you think that the hours that
have put in here are put in here make
sense are they high low my understanding
is that this comes I just taking the
representatives testimony the prime
sponsor testimony um from from another
state we train people well over these
numbers um so they would not change the
amount of training that we would be
doing it would in fact be well below
what we currently do how how important
do you think it is to even have numbers
in
here because we're going to exceed these
numbers by a significant factor I would
not consider them to be very helpful
unless you wanted to enforce against
someone let's say a clerk of court is
required to do 12 hours that they um you
want to ring them up on an employment
issue and say you were you did not
comply with a requirement of your job um
that's the scenario in which I would
most likely see it come up but it would
not it would not affect for us how much
training people
receive and how did how were the numbers
gotten maybe that's not a question for
you my understanding from the prime
sponsors testimony and support of it in
committee was that she had seen them in
another state but I could be
misapprehend what she
said okay so there no no no I don't well
I was going to say they're somewhat
arbitrary so they're not but that's
probably too harsh uh 12 hours of C is a
a common requirement in most
jurisdictions for attorneys so I think
the intention either in that state or
for this Prime sponsor was to have twice
as much for a judge which may seem like
um a lot and I and it it is a lot I
think for attorney to to meet that in a
typical year um but for the judges they
typically receive much more thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you very
much are there any further questions or
from folks out there now I believe
you've received a copy of Representative
Maguire's Amendment representative
Maguire would you like to explain so um
the key expense in this bill is hiring
of a Judicial training
coordinator um so I thought it better to
align that with the budget year so this
moves the effective date to July 1st
2025 um and the the uh related to the
questions representative eel was talking
this also I I don't believe in in sort
of micromanaging what the what the
Judiciary is doing so this cut out most
of those numbers and left it up to them
except for the initial training of
Judges which is the example that most
people use like the one we heard today
um and so that's that's what the
amendment does it gives them more
flexibility but it says it does it moves
cycle do you would you like to comment
or do you have any
yeah
one of the things that I enjoyed ever so
much working with the Judiciary in the
special
committee is how collaborative both they
and the committee saw this job to
be to the point where when one of the
subcommittees met that was going to
bring forward some
suggestions the Judiciary before the
suggestions were made informed the
subcommittee how they were already
implementing them because they had been
talking with us individually they had
been either in attendance or monitoring
our committee meetings we are out um out
eyes they are in eyes and we saw that as
meshing rather than as
antagonistic so I have full confidence
that the Judiciary will increase the the
amount of training that is done
initially and
subsequently um again it's been a joy to
chare this special committee because
they wanted to work with us and we
wanted to work with
answer nobody would ever accuse you of
being
liberal in the classic definition of
liberal they
should anyway there any questions for
the chair of Health un
Services seeing none oh one more
represent MCU not not a question but one
more point that I the other reason for
taking out the numbers was it occurred
to me that the amount of training that a
20-year judge versus a two-year judge
needs is quite probably quite different
and but the bill as written says this
many hours for everybody right so I
thought I'd just take some of that out
yeah sure well as a lawyer who is no
longer practicing just from the
standpoint of the continuing education
requirements I agree with you and
sometimes they make sense in the early
years but after you've been around a
while they make a little less sense so
but you did decide to leave the Sha in
here yeah I didn't focus
on okay thank
you
the pleasure of the division would we
any more discussion on representative
Maguire's Amendment or would the
division Like to Move Along on yeah can
I move my Amendment yeah you certainly
you okay the motion has been made and
seconded by representative cambrell to
support representative Maguire's
Amendment 0916 H is our other any more
questions
comments yes I I I have a I like the
amendment a lot I just still wonder
about the shell
part represent McGuire you'll take the
shell out right if if that's what people
want that's fine with you want to change
that to
may7 if the if the Judiciary has a TR
trouble with it seems like that makes
me
yes can you state your name for the
record
pleas hi I'm representative Caitlyn cab
apologize that I'm late we were
executing a bill down the hall I just
wanted to state that this bill did
initially say may however our retired
chief justice Bob Lyn felt that it was
not a 73a issue to say shell and to
require the training and so it was
amended to say shell in judiciary
intentionally
we actually heard by the representative
from the judicial branch that may would
be more appropriate versus shell no just
respect to the former Chief Justice and
she she did raise that issue in our
committee as well and he respectfully
disagreed and changed it to
May so do we
care our he kind of felt as as though
you know we mandate training all the
time in other branches as well even in
in the executive branch so there's no
reason why we can't do it here was his
argument back
so well here from representative eel and
then our former judge hwit over here as
far as the mayor shell before we act on
the
amendment I I you know with all due
respect to um representative Lynn I
guess it just really gives me some pause
when we have the general Council of the
judicial branch sitting here saying that
they do have constitutional issues and
that they will be the ones that would be
forced to um enforce the statute so um I
don't know it's up to the committee I'd
prefer to see May representa huitt is a
former judge and
lawyer you like to comment don't forget
to push your
mic
Point um it isn't just the business of
shall and may if you read the if you
read the first
paragraph I want to I don't want to
be cruded but they it almost appears
that they're selling
something now you're talking about uh
high quality judicial branch training
and
uh providing judges administrators and
Court staff with a reasonable
opportunity to fulfill any mandatory
orientation and initial required
training that that pretty much creates
a
a kind of a box to put everything in and
it would appear to me that what you have
is a a series of different kind times of
different kinds of employees that you're
dealing with
uh you're dealing with judges who have
been on the bench for a short time and a
long time uh the same the same is true
with some of the Court
staff so that to just put a a blanket
out there I think is a little bit a
um
like sales sales pitch or something uh
now and of course there is judicial
training is a lot different from every
every other kind and in some cases you
know the 73a situation I can
apply but this just that sentence just
strikes me as being something that goes
a little bit over the edge as far as
trying to create a program that's going
to be successful and I don't think you
need I don't I don't think you need to
dictate to judges and and uh uh Court
staff U what what a a reasonable what a
reasonable workload is or what what kind
of the things need to be done in in
point of fact uh a lot of this a lot of
this stuff is difficult to uh to
imagine and it's even worse in the in
the field of uh
bail where the work is all done out in
the field but I I I agree that there can
be a a
training program
developed separate and apart from what
is normally part of the judicial
training uh concept which practically
practically every judge goes through at
one time or another and uh so I I think
that that that sentence could use a
little bit of
work we can talk about that represented
Griffin remember we do have a motion on
the
floor yeah I
um I had more trouble with the shell
under the original Law than I do with
the shell under the amendment because
basically the amendment doesn't dictate
the number of hours or anything else it
just says there will be training so I I
really have no problem with this shell
as it's written in the amendment as it
does just deal with training versus some
legal matter it's training versus a
legal matter okay representative evil
thank you um I would like to ask uh the
representative from the judicial branch
if she has a different feeling on the
amendment than the original bill which
goes in part to what representative
excuse me um I think the the prime
sponsor when she had originally done
this had tried to mitigate the sh I
should not try to speak for her but by
adding as directed by the Chief Justice
of the Supreme Court to that sentence so
that it could for example if it needed
to be an extreme labor shortage or
something to that effect it could be
waved it could be moved that there was
an element of judicial internal
management that was still considered in
the structure of that sentence um so I I
don't believe that when I had reviewed
her draft I changed that shell there uh
I think I had left that because she had
left an out that the Supreme Court could
uh through the Chief Justice could
direct
otherwise yeah I'm happy to have the
vote and then if it's uh you
know if if there're serious problems we
can do something all right the motion
has been made by representative Maguire
second by represent cambrell to support
0916 okay
just and whenever the clerk is ready
please call the role this is not the
significant
this
okay so we're voting on Amendment
H and
passes
yes
yeses
chair
practice
okay all right so um the motion
is ought to pass as amended by
representative hu seconded by
representative
okay I'm really playing with fire on
this
okay need to add you to my list okay
representative Maguire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeny yes representative
camell yes clerk votes yes
representative huitt yes representative
grassie yes and chair Wier
me that's all right I was so nervous
about making do you vote Yes yes oh yes
oh you do okay that's right n Z ought to
amend thank you
all representative long I assume you're
1199 so just for the uh committee this
was passed on a Voice vote back on
February 1st after a motion
was made to lay the bill on the
table by 187 188 so a close vote there
um and it was a division vote as far as
it lay on the table this came out of the
children and family law
you thank you
uh hosit 1199 concentrates on youth
homelessness through the office of child
advocate municipalities in the state of
New Hampshire appropriate tens of
millions of dollars yearly in services
to adult homelessness 2020 point in time
count of individuals in New Hampshire
experience in homelessness revealed a
21% increase from
2019 with approximately 15,000 youth
data shows that young adults experience
in homelessness found that most most
participants first experienc
homelessness as a minor as a minor data
also shows that minor experienced
homelessness is an adverse childhood
experience often to referred to as Aces
uh the data collection from the OCA
would Aid in assuring governing bodies
are appropriately funds that delivered
for the taxpayers and reducing Services
needed for those homeless youth entering
their adult stages uh two years ago uh
the city of Manchester received a letter
uh from the governor saying that uh the
state had appropriated to Manchester $44
million in the last four years for
homelessness uh it wasn't to the city of
Manchester it was to the
nonprofits uh and also uh my part-time
job as an alderman in Manchester I've
noticed in the last two years that uh
homeless the homeless population is
getting younger uh 19 year olds 20 year
olds um and also I get a lot of calls
from the uh School District uh on uh
children that are sleeping in cars or or
they're not in encampments thank god um
we Manchester had appropriated money to
immediately remove any child and parent
from an
encampment um and I know uh the city of
Manchester in the last two years has
spent from their General funds $5.5
million towards towards homelessness and
I just think that if we could catch it
at the early stages we may be able to
help prevent uh adult
homelessness um that's why I um agreed
with this uh this uh scenario uh of of
uh the officer child advocate um looking
at youth homelessness I know in
Manchester we don't have a complete
circle on youth homelessness there's
little patches here and there and I find
that the same in the state of Hampshire
so I think this would help in in getting
our arms around uh youth homelessness
within within the
state
thanks Mike do we have an updated fiscal
not this is kind of old but maybe it
hasn't changed it's
1127 this bill came through as
introduced so it hasn't needed to change
the bill hasn't been amended thanks
you're
welcome questions for the good
representative from
Manchester you don't have enough
Maguire all I don't and um I don't think
I voted for this bill but
um so exactly what will this person do
to to um to help homelessness that's not
part of the already millions of dollars
you talked about uh this is uh thank you
for the questions representative this
this is spefic specifically for youth
homelessness we have um Continuum of
cares uh throughout the state in
different regions that um address
homelessness uh it's adult homelessness
and I think a concentration on youth
homelessness uh would would help this
help the state really yeah but
specifically what will the person do
will they go out and look for Youth and
cars will they you know what are they
going to do yeah they're going to
looking for nonprofits or for-profits
that identify uh that work with youth
there is no I mean for 10 years I I've
been looking at um the silos in these
different uh there's no complete circle
in anything we attempt to do in the city
of Manchester it's it's all silos
everybody every nonprofit's got their
own gig and they want their own money
for that gig and they don't work with
the other uh nonprofits in in Manchester
we're forcing them you don't get any
money from us unless you collaborate
with the other nonprofits that are on
your same issue and that I would hope
that that would be one of the things
that they'd be looking at is identify
who's working with youth
homelessness what are the gaps how can
we complete that Circle by getting all
those entities
together
no and if I may uh uh Mr chairman I I
I'm not I heard there was a problem
that's why the motion to
table um but I've never been able to
identify what the problem
was all right well thanks for your
testimony and I see some folks out there
probably from the child
advocacy
group believe we received a
folks and just State your your name for
the record
together good morning chair Lan and
committee um I don't think I've gotten
to talk to all of you before I am Lisa
masio I am the attorney at the office of
child advocate so I'm essentially the
deputy to the child advocate candra
Sanchez who is unable to be here today
as well as do the policy and legislative
work um the office of child advocate is
a state agency but we are an independent
oversight agency so we are not in any of
those silos we are not part of
DHHS or the Department of Education
although we do have oversight over those
agencies we're actually administratively
attached to
das um so we did give some um testimony
but I would be happy to answer
representative Maguire's specific
question about how this would actually
work if that would be
helpful we are not going to just walk
around peeking in cars to see if there
are children in there um although maybe
we will but probably not um so generally
the way our office works is under our
statute which is 21v um we are an
independent agency and completely
confidential so we take calls from
anyone in the state it could be judges
or attorneys it could be social workers
it could be Folks at school parents
directly from children um we have a
number of different ways to outreach us
we've actually just started a text line
specifically for children so currently
we take calls and are looking only
though at system involved children so
right now our intakes can only be for
children that are currently system
involved whether it's with dcyf the
child protection side Juvenile Justice
it could involve the schools it could
involve any of the res residential
facilities um what this and so then when
we get a call we look into it what is
going on depending who called we can see
into dcf's Bridges see what's going on
with the case we can connect all those
silos that's really our primary one of
our primary jobs that is what makes our
agency appropriate for this position and
makes us sort of unique we can call a
meeting and call in dcyf the school the
attorney doe the teachers the providers
bring everyone to the same table and
figure out what's going on for that
particular child what this bill would do
would be to allow us to interact with
children who are not currently system
involved because there is a big gap
there as representative long stated that
a lot of Youth homelessness may not be
system involved yet there are a number
of children still in their intact
families which is great but that are
struggling Ling with homelessness or
very unstable housing those kids
currently we do not have access to under
our current statute so that's one of um
really the Boon of this bill and why it
would be appropriate to put it into our
independent agency to be able to contact
those children so that may be calls from
schools the mckin vento lays on it may
be calls from Neighbors from concerned
daycare providers um right now if we get
a call like and the child is not system
involved we have to refer them elsewhere
and as representative long stated
there's not really a very connected
network of how to help that child and
that family without forcing them into
Child Protection involvement so but
maybe we will go around and look in cars
if that works and let me let Emily
introduce herself as well no I should
know this but are you administratively
attached to another state agency Das the
Department of administrative services so
we are independent but we do um
essentially just for human resources and
and sort of business accounting they
don't oversee us Cassandra Sanchez is
the head of our agency representative
McGuire thank you so how many such calls
where do you get where someone would
fall into this category but you you're
forced to say go talk to somebody else I
wish I could answer that question but
unfortunately our data collection system
which we are trying to fix right now is
not doesn't really allow us to track
that if we get a call that we don't have
oversight over we don't have a code for
that it's basically just we refer out I
can tell you though that in the last
year we've had calls for 142 missing
children that were dcyf involved so we
can take jurisdiction over those kids I
think the flips as well as some pretty
nine since January of serious concerns
of human sex trafficking for children
that are system involved so again that's
that tiny percentage that our system
involves so presumably and I think
Waypoint can give you some better
data if this position were to be created
in our office and folks knew that we
could now handle these calls we expect
there to be a flood of calls from our
Network that already knows what we do
from all those teachers counselors
daycare providers you know law
enforcement that now know oh there's an
extra thing we can call the OCA about
and they're going to give us that same
lens and that same resources as we
currently have for system involved so I
wish I had a better number but I think
Waypoint has sort of a a global idea of
how many of those kids are out there and
and if you got such a call who would you
send them to it is very case specific so
even our current cases is you know we
have an intake process with a pretty
thorough you know sort of initial
interview of what exactly is going on
who are you already involved and where
do you live you know are you connected
to a school of other resources so we
would then work with all of those folks
around that particular family but in
doing that work we then also see the
gaps in the system Statewide because we
get calls across the state no that's not
what I meant I'm sorry you when you
can't help somebody because they're not
system involved right you say well I'm
sorry I can't help you because and you
say please you know go call HHS or
somebody right so that I'm not a social
worker so I don't actually take the
intake calls but I can tell you
generally um we would refer them to
community providers like Waypoint if we
know they have Sheltering needs or
wherever they are in the state
um we could refer to some DHHS Services
typically we're not encouraging folks to
get involved with like Child Protection
if that's not it just it really depends
on but that is also how we identify
those gaps we realize there is no one to
send them to and that's where sometimes
we bring forward new policies we talk
with the providers we bring forward
legislation to fill those needs all
right one last question so if if a child
is homeless wouldn't it be appropriate
that they become in foster care no no
the statute actually very explicitly
says that cannot remove a child from
their family based on financial issues
and homelessness often falls into that
that the parent is meeting the child's
basic needs they're clothed they're fed
they're getting to school they're
getting medical care so homelessness
alone is absolutely not a reason to call
dcyf or to remove a child because
removing a child from their family is
actually very
traumatic all right but then then the
family would be getting homelessness
help right so that's not necessarily
what the DCF system is set up for is to
DCF but I mean in general that's not
a the way I I understand this and maybe
I'm wrong is that these are not kids in
families are they or are they they they
may be kids in families yes I think one
of the other advantages of this bill so
our office is able to service youth up
to age 21 or 22 currently if their
system involved and it's voluntary above
18 um so it is that transition period as
well though that's really challenging
for kids to successfully launch into
adulthood when when they're struggling
with this particular issue and as
representative long said there is a gap
thank are there any further questions oh
would you like I'll just introduce
myself I'm Emily Lawrence the deputy
advocacy director with Waypoint um and I
have testimony here as well that I
emailed the committee and my colleague
Aaron George Kelly who runs Our Youth
Services Program which includes Our
Youth and Young Adult homelessness
programs um uh also emailed you
testimony those programs include Street
Outreach programs so we do have people
that go out onto the streets um to look
for homeless Youth and Young adults uh
they also include drop in Cent so that
they can come do their laundry get some
food do their homework if they need to
or look for a job um and then we have
the shelter in Manchester which was just
opened in 2020 the fall of 2022 which is
really the only overnight shelter in New
Hampshire for that age range of 18 to
25 um and what we've learned is that
that age range not only is critical to
prevention but is is tricky because they
often don't feel comfortable going to an
adult homeless shelter um there's still
some of them are transitioning out of
foster care or other services and so
that's there's often a a kind of a drop
at that point where they are at high
risk of becoming homeless um our shelter
does not just provide shelter we
actually provide case management for
them so we would help them to be looking
for a job to figure out who their
supports could be and their resources um
it's kind of a wraparound care that we
have for them then we also have
Transitional Living Program and that is
again for that young adult age group um
as they're looking to get on their feet
to get a job to figure out how they can
get a car and get around um we have
housing are there any
questions seeing none thank you very
you I did have a question for
representative
long
so on the most recent fiscal note that
we received it shows an appropriation of
$150,000 but nothing for 26 and 27 was
it the intent maybe that that would be
funded in the budget next time around
see nodding heads so yeah I I was hoping
it would deliver what we're hoping it
would deliver and then be included in
thanks all right any uh it's up to the
the pleasure of the division what they'd
like to do it's a
$150,000 yes
sir sure you got a few
minutes and your name for the record
please hi uh Keith kenning I'm the Avis
director at Waypoint Emily is my
colleague just I just want to say that
um there is no doubt there's a quiet
crisis going on here on homelessness
with kids um I was just down at our
shelter down in Manchester we have 14
beds down there and every night we have
to do a lottery and we turn around 15
kids away every night and this is just
18 to 25 year olds we don't even touch
the 13 to 18 year olds because of the
Leal complications when we were asked
how many more beds we would need just in
Manchester to deal with the 13 to 25
year olds the answer was probably 20
more so every night we turn children
away the question was what about in
Rochester we probably need 10 or 15 beds
to deal with the homeless kids there um
it is everywhere it is growing I had a
friend one time say to me some issues
are like trying to shovel fog this is
one of those issues it's difficult to
know exactly what's going on because the
kids are fleeing they're either fleeing
some kind of
you know Anger from their parents or
something's going on they're sofa
surfing on people's sofas every night um
it's a real crisis when I was I've been
following these issues on homelessness
in the state for 22 years and 14 years
ago I went up to Claremont and at that
time one in 10 children in the Claremont
School System were homeless at some
point through the year and I know that
probably the number of homeless kids in
Manchester now just Manchester probably
outnumbers the number that was through
the entire State probably 20 years ago
so we're seeing more and more and more
of it it is a crisis I think
representative Maguire your question is
a good one what are we doing I I think
what we're doing is we're trying to
figure out what's happening out there so
we can solve the problem no engineer
goes to a site and orders the steel for
the foundation before they do a survey
first to find out what's happening we
have to have a centralized place that
people can start accumulating the
information about the homelessness in
this state in order to answer the
problem and so I see this as a really
important First Step a small investment
to start accumulating this data so we
can get a better feel for what's
happening and it is a crisis out there
when kids are out on the street and have
no doubt about it I think the national
rep reports show that within 72 hours of
a child being on the street they're
going to be either approached for drugs
or sexual trafficking so these kids are
incredibly vulnerable and so Waypoint is
doing everything they can and we're
really proud of our work we're going to
have a sleepout coming up here we're
having one in conquer we're having one
in Rochester we're having one in
Manchester but we really need to get a
better idea of what's Happening
throughout the entire State and I I I
think this position is incredibly
important for that so thank you for your
time would you take a question or
two was going to go to representative
Sweeney first so thank you represent
thank you chairman thank you for being
here thank you for the testimony how
much would 20 beds cost to add 20 beds
to the facility um so don't hold me just
to this but I think it costs us about
$500,000 a year to run that facility to
manester I can get that number for you
okay um we're incredibly efficient if
you go down there we'd love to give you
a tour um the kids have they're all
bunked in one room um they have like a
5x 10t section that they have a bed and
just one little Locker that they can go
into that they can put their stuff into
the night I mean it's nothing it's it's
nothing fancy by any means but we have
one of our children um actually at this
point is in college trying to get their
college degree we actually had a
pregnant teen that um was there and we
also had a teen that ended up graduating
from high school um that was at our
shelter and our staff went to them and
helped them with the cap and gown so
they could watch him graduate so I I
think what Emily and and Lisa were
talking about which is these are not
irredeemable lives and the reason that
kids 18 to 25 don't want to be with a
lot of the chronically homeless is they
don't want to be listen laying next to
people that are 50 years old that have
been in the system for 35 years we need
to get them as early as possible and get
them turned around and between jobs core
and high school and college we can save
these kids' lives if we get there at the
right time but if we don't know who they
are and we don't know the numbers we
can't possibly solve the
problem followup I get but you've been
the efforts in Manchester turned away
kids because there weren't enough beds
so we do know the problem we do know who
they are we just need more beds it seems
to be not more staff no so there are two
issues thank you for the question
representative one is we don't we don't
have the beds at this time but I can
tell you with assurity that we turn away
children every night because we have to
do a lot of system for who's coming in
there the other problem is Staff it is
it is difficult finding Staffing because
if you're going to do this right you
know a lot of times people think they'll
say well there's an old house just let
kids stay there that's not the solution
you you need they need structure just
like like any 18 to 25 year old right I
mean everything we see about brain
development is that these are the last
important years of children having their
brains developed to do the right thing
and so it's a combination of us having
more funding to have the beds for the
kids and then that funding would also
have to cover the the extra staff we
would need to cover to make sure that
children are getting what they need so
it's a combination of those two things
but I I use that number just to give you
some sense of what's happening every
night in Manchester I mean
representative long knows it too well
the the money is spending and the
majority of our money in the state and
rightfully so goes to adults because we
haven't had this crisis right I mean it
makes sense that the money would go to
the adults to take care of them first
and families through domestic violence
shelters but but what we're seeing is
this new growing problem and we have to
figure out a way to deal with it so I'm
sorry if it went on too long
representative lman uh representative
Maguire no
yes um representative grassy like to
make a motion
move ought to pass motion's been made to
ought to pass a here
second second second by representative
hwit when
the clerk is ready we'll call the role
please discuss oh would you like
discussion represent Maguire yeah thank
you so I have the same sort of concerns
I think that representative Sweeny had
with asking his questions because if we
spend this $100,000 a year on this
that's $100,000 a year we're not putting
into actual Services right and so the
problem is not finding kids that need
Pro need help we hearing that there's so
many of
them that's the problem right so so I
don't see to me it doesn't sound like
this is going to help that much compared
to extra beds extra food extra whatever
that kind of thing Mr chairman
yes representative like to speak to my
motion as well um the thing is is is is
I disagree and I think this is a very
important thing I've had to I've visited
the way point facil in Rochester and I
think it's tremendous what they're able
to do for children and the thing is is
that there is that age group that is
sort of left out left out in the cold um
that they're not they're they're too old
for foster but they're not old enough
really to get into the into into the
homeless shelter situation that he spoke
about with 50y olds and 60 year olds
that are out there and the the other
people that are that are that have
problems and what this advocate's
position is supposed to be doing is is
to be and if if you look at the bill it
will identify programs it will identify
other sources of money and resources
that are available in the community I
mean Rochester needs to have a facility
where we can House people I mean they
have it basically just it's a day
program allows people to do their their
laundry it allows them to get a meal it
allows them to have a place to do their
homework I will tell you I have
personally witnessed waiting at a park
and ride to come here and
conquered car sitting in a parking ride
and all of a sudden I see two heads Pop
I see one head pop up in the front seat
I see a head pop up in the back seat you
see somebody get out of the car run into
the woods you know what they're doing
and then the other guy gets out in the
back gets his backpack out and he's
shuffling his books guy comes back and
the other guy goes out into the woods
Guy starts shaving right in his car
right there with bottled water in the in
in in a period where it was cold
out now Waypoint probably wasn't
available for them at that that early in
the
morning but the thing is is that what
this person will do is it will
identify resources available and maybe
maybe it will also identify where there
are no resources available where we need
them and I think it's this is a small
amount to pay certainly we have to do
more for housing we all know that and
we're there are groups out there that
are talking about housing all over the
place most of them talk about the older
crowd I've also looked at housing for
what are we going to do for for this age
group as well that this bill wants to
identify and wants to to focus on this
is very very important I think this is
even more important than the older
population that we have out there that
is homeless because these kids it's not
their
choice some people when you get to a
certain age it's you know and and it is
it is their choice to be homeless but I
don't I think very few people make that
choice but these people they don't even
have that this is not a for them at all
they're just stuck in this
situation and uh whether it be family or
whatever situation happens to be um this
is small money to solve and and to help
start solving a major problem in the
state thank you representative grassy I
couldn't agree with you more
um yes representative swe followed by
representative huitt thank you Mr
chairman I I don't think anyone here
disagrees that homelessness especially
especially among younger members of our
society is a pressing issue for the
grant
State the reason why I can't support
this bill as as as written today uh in
the fiscal note this is utilizing
American Rescue plan act funds to get
started on the position and then it
would go into the budget afterward so
we're using onetime money to create a a
staff level position that would then be
continued by Future taxpayer money my
position would be if there is this
available American Rescue plan act funds
available to us we should be using that
onto the infrastructure of getting more
beds getting more facilities up and
running online to actually house these
individuals as soon as possible instead
of hiring a staffer that will identify
I'm not sure of how many resources are
out there that aren't being utilized to
the maximum currently uh and I would be
disheartened if there were hundreds of
thousands of dollars out there in grant
funding opportunity and nonprofit funds
that people are out there they may be
advertising we have this help available
but but nobody is directing those in
need towards it um so I'm not sure how
they're going to identify new funds that
are just sitting there that people
aren't aware of that aren't using I
think they can identify every need in
the book uh for for future spending and
future funds to to actually address the
issues of homelessness I just don't see
the staffer being able to do it uh and I
think the the use of the the arpa money
can be used more effectively actually
providing homes and and beds to these
homeless uh the youth and and to all
homeless of all ages so that's just what
to uh representative hwit followed by
representative
grassy well the the the concept of not
funding something like this uh in
addition to not providing any Services
kind of sends out a message that well we
this really isn't the kind of pro kind
of problem we need to deal with
today uh we can we can know look for
other things to do with this money
um but when you're looking at what the
reason is you're spending you're not
spending it just because people are out
of out of a home you're spending the
money because these are people that are
different from the average person who
who is out of a home uh there's there's
homeless people all over the place uh
and typically over the years you you
find most of the homeless people in in
the upper age category and those those
are the people who actually if you give
it be a little bit curious about it they
PE they are people who have a little
more ability to find
stuff kids don't kids have have all
kinds of reasons why not to do
it I just look at the drug program Pro
problem and the
uh the relationship among children even
into the upper age of of child
childness uh is an indication that there
is there is a problem that needs to be
solved and just providing a place to do
it doesn't meet doesn't meet the
requirements of getting them educated
and out of that situation so I I think
that it's worth doing now and that all
also doing this now could uh could
encourage other
organizations that may have the ability
to do this to stop and think about what
they're doing and whether the whether
the money they're spending is being
spent as as critically as it could be
thank you representative grass yeah I I
I I have to disagree I you know I agree
with everything that representative you
had said I think that's that's very
important that who whoever gets this
position could help basically drum up
more resources for this the money in
this is not going to solve our problem
we're not going to get you you can't
even get one bed for $100,000 uh I mean
because you have to find a facility to
put those beds in first and you can get
a facility if you don't have beds in it
and if you don't have staff it you don't
you don't have really any place to put
people this is small money that's not
going to make a dent in beds and
Facilities but what it is is it
leverages a lot of other resources and
money and I think representative you
would hit it on the head that this
person get gets out there works with
communities works with other groups
works with the religious communities in
in in in these cities and towns to be
able to bring them together to solve
this problem and I think this is just a
good start we're not you know it if next
year we say you know we didn't see
anything happen we we don't think this
is worth the money we can we can deal
with it at that time and maybe we don't
fund it for a second year but the thing
is I think get the program started and
let's see what we can do and maybe
there'll be some results happening from
this thing um I think this is a good
program I think this is someone we need
to lead our efforts to solve the problem
for youth homelessness um you know too
many kids are out there couch surfing
and like I said it's it's not their
choice whether they're leaving an
abusive family or they've been thrown
out of their house I had a kid lived
with me one time for six to eight months
uh because they got thrown out of their
house and we gave them the opportunity
to become productive a productive
citizens um which their family didn't
feel they wanted to to work with them at
all at that time it was it was a
difficult situation but the thing is is
that a lot of families a lot of kids
don't have that
opportunity and I think that this is
small dollars that will not make any
difference if you try to put it out
there for resources
today but will help us for resources
tomorrow
represent
CS yes I was wondering if I could ask do
you have people that do this job right
now and how many for what you would call
population so that might take both of us
um the office of child advocate only
serves children so we have two current
we call them assistant child Advocates
they're essentially ud's positions who
do this work with the system involved
children so when they take a call they
are social workers in fact most of us
actually used to work for dcyf or
Juvenile Justice work within that system
but also pulling in resources exactly as
you're saying from outside the system
that other state agencies really can't
do and sometimes that Community Services
can't do so we we are lucky that we get
to bridge that Gap kind of to touch both
state agency resources as well as
Community
Resources I agree with you
representative Sweeney there's probably
not some bucket of money sitting
somewhere that no one's discovered what
we do is make those
connections creative problem solving
with all these different siloed agencies
that's what we currently do for children
who are impacted by the system this bill
Not only would give us money to create a
third on buds person position focused on
this issue but also would expand our
jurisdiction to allow us to touch those
non system involved children because
that's really where our office would
love to be addressing this issue but
currently the way 21v is written we can
only work with system involved children
so um I believe some of the community
advocacy groups do already do this for
adults but as Emily and Keith both said
this particular population of children
is both head hesitant to reach out and
doesn't feel comfortable in the current
systems so while this position wouldn't
be creating new beds it would be making
connections and in fact could be making
a connection like representative grassy
said of finding a kinship or fictive kin
person in that child or young person's
life to work something out work
something out with the school can we
find this kid a a bed somewhere so it's
it's really that creative problem
solving piece that this position and we
do plan to put it in our next budget yes
so whoever answered that asked that
question earlier we are going to put
into our next budget round a third
ombud's position but this bill allows us
to expand our scope a little bit it's
not just a matter of like funding a
position it's allowing our office to
work with those kids and try and avoid
them becoming system involved by just
creatively finding resources to help
them is that answer
your thank
you yeah having worked in the the
homelessness field for adults as well
the thing is I in straford County I know
we have many people who deal with the
adult population to try to bring
resources together I mean just look at
your local welfare director usually
they're the person who's doing a lot of
those connections the local cap agencies
they're doing a lot of those connections
so there are people that are doing it
for the adult population they're doing
it people for children that are in the
system there's just that Gap where we
have no services for those those those
middle I I just like to point out that
18 to 25 year old is considered an adult
and you know we keep talking children
and yet I heard earlier that 13 yearolds
show up and they get turned away for
legal reasons I can understand but I'd
be more concerned about those 12 to 16
year old 17 year olds and I I would
think that 18 to 20 25 year
olds would get covered by the adult
system that's what you would think just
a response there are kids that are below
the age of 18 that are not in the
system and that's where the the child
that I had was below 18 wasn't in the
system didn't have any interaction with
DCF uh was what we considered a good kid
but situations happened to the family
that things changed and she had to leave
her family um she was she was being
thrown out on the streets and and um and
and you know we took her in so she
didn't have to interact with the system
but there are there are places and
situations now particular where there
are a lot of kids and when you talk to
some of your High School principles
you'll find out there are kids that are
not in the
system that are sleeping in their cars
or couch surfing and those children
would be picked up they're under the age
of
18 seeing no further questions a motion
was made by representative grass he said
exed by hwit to support the passage of
1199 when the clerk is ready please call
the role okay um this is a motion of aop
pass on House Bill
1199 uh representative Maguire no
representative Griffin no representative
Sweeny no Representative cambrell no
clerk votes I representative hwit yes
representative grassie yes
representative
wer
no and chair leean yes yes so uh the
to4 all right are you going to offer an
amendment I mean a motion of itl I think
representative
Sweeny representative Sweeney I'll move
it it's been moved and seconded by
representative
sure yes
yes
all right welcome to division one at uh
1:00 we have
1279 relative to the payment by the
state of a portional retirement system
contribution to political subdivision
employees anyone out there like to come
forward and speak to the
bill and you please identify yourself
for the
record
good afternoon members of the committee
my name is Keen Ming Wong tax policy
council with the New Hampshire
Department of
Revenue good afternoon uh I'm Bruce canu
I'm the municipal Bureau supervisor at
sure I I I apology uh my apologies I I
don't have my car with me right now but
I can come over and and write it for
you yes yeah y um uh the purpose is that
um for for us to speak today uh the
department doesn't have any opinion any
position on the bill but it just wanted
to to highlight a certain um um item
that maybe the committee making consider
uh in terms of um in terms of the timing
of the information flow for the
Department to to get information in
terms of um Tax rating setting process
further at present um the Appropriations
for a
municipality or contributions to the
retirement system are very likely uh
funded at 100% right now as the budgets
are um de developed and voted on very
shortly and this is reminiscent of I
think it was two years ago perhaps very
similar phenomenon where the state ended
up um paying 7 and a.
half% what that means for us at Dr as we
get ready for property tax rate setting
commencing on October 1st we need to
have a precise reconciliation of any
state revenues that are being f Ed or
sent to a
municipality so what happened two years
ago it's looking like the same situation
could
unfold where it's
optimal if in this case the retirement
system can calculate what the 7 A half%
is for each municipality in dollar terms
and communicate that to the Department
of Revenue so that we make sure that
each municipality
estimated revenues which would impact
their the local the town or city tax
rate uh is
accurate um so I guess our request would
be is if the bill could reflect the same
deadline that agencies um in in agencies
are under 20 RSA
21j colon
35 I'm trying to remember the
section um is October 1st so the
revenues from various State agencies are
due to Dr by October 1st and that allows
us at that point in theory to begin to
calculate the the property tax rates um
the bill itself contains no um comment
on on when such information would flow
to Dr so we thought we would at least
ask ask that it be entertained as a a
possible
Amendment represent McGuire thank you
thank you for coming and taking my
question just for interest um so the
effective date is July 1 so that's well
before but but you're saying we should
require municipalities to let you know
this information by October 1st no it
would be it would be the retirement
system that will do the calculation as
we understand it from the prior
experience municipalities report various
uh data to retirement at year end June
30 and it takes retirement a period of
time to then determine what the I guess
it would be the fiscal 25 contribution
is going to be and from that they could
then calculate s and a half% of it so
um it it can delay the property tax
rates if we have to wait for that number
I understand so
Yeah
question representative wer I guess I
I'll wait I'll wait till later this this
isn't uh the area these gentlemen are
offering in about what this bill says to
me anyway thank you I'll talk
later are there any uh other questions
comments seeing none I guess you're free
to go thank you thank
you
so a question for again Mr
Hoffman the fiscal note is quite dated
is we have an update as far as
the 27.1 three million or is that pretty
much oh Marty sure we take the mic
please I can't I can speak to the fiscal
node because the bill hasn't been
amended okay so we still have the
introduced version of this all right
thanks yeah I I knew uh Mr Hoffman could
handle that I I just to kind of follow
up on on the previous testimony just to
explain the mechanics of how this has
worked in the past um for the
committee's edification the the numbers
in the fiscal note are
represent uh contributions made in the
prior fiscal year rolled forward at the
payroll growth assumption for each of
the respective member groups which is um
uh 2.75 for um police and fire and um
2.25 for teachers so we just took the
prior fiscal year numbers roll them
forward to to get that number and then
the the second year of the fiscal note
is a roll forward on those assumptions
again so we the employers report to us
essentially not not quite in real time
but on a one-month lag and the rates are
a percentage of covered payroll so we
can estimate or individual municipality
your school district can can estimate
what their payroll costs are going to be
next October but they're not going to
know what those costs are until they've
already paid the checks people have left
there's vacancies there's hires things
like that so so we don't give them a
projected amount to pay you know going
forward so uh in the past when the state
subsidy um was was in effect uh through
uh fiscal 11 I believe um the we had the
employers pay 75% of the rate and then
the other 25% in that in that last
fiscal year was coming from the state of
New Hampshire I understand that the
folks from Dr budgets are already set
for fiscal 25 and that rate is funded at
100% of covered payroll so if the state
was reimbursing over the course of um um
beginning july24 that would be Revenue
that they didn't wouldn't have to raise
taxes on I think that would FL itself
out after that first year um the way it
would be is is um beginning in July
employers would be reporting June wages
and paying contributions on a percent of
those wages in August they'd be
reporting July wages and paying a
percent and so on and then um you know
that's in a perfect world where all the
numbers add up and there's no
reconciliation issues occasionally with
employer reporting you know there are
some discrepancies and it's it's
statutorily due um by the 15 of the
month but we may have have to do some
post reporting reconciliation to to Drew
up the numbers so it's it's um it's not
as clean as you know we're not sending a
bill to to the employer for the next
quarter or the next fiscal year we're
taking the taking a percentage of their
month all right
now thank you welcome um
what I'm interested in is the rates that
were the employer pays the fire police
and teachers and so on and what what
they pay and what the employee pays do
you have those off the top of your head
I I can give you a pretty close
approximation off the top of my head um
for group one uh employees and Teachers
Pay 7% out of their you know pay check
each period towards nhrs contributions
it's 11.55 for police and 11.8 for fire
and those are those are exact numbers on
the um on the employer side the one I am
least confident in I know it's in this
range but it's it's U between 13 and 14%
of
pay um the teacher employers of teachers
pay 19.6% of pay and um police and fire
are in the 29 and a half to 30% of pay
range I mean and I get and I'll forward
this over it's posted on the website no
that's that's uh cuz I remember when in
2011 when we took out the contribution
from the state we raised those all up to
those percentages they are now correct
and that made up for the fact that the
state wasn't contributing everybody
forgets that when they keep coming in
and saying oh oh you owe it to us you
promised us and I I remember in that
little town I I have lived in since 1970
when this Retirement System first came
in the only people in my town that were
in the retirement system were the
teachers and since that time um there
were on call firemen there were police
that were paid parttime and since that
time now we have probably 25 employees
that are in this retirement system
people forget that the system in 68 had
very few of these Town employees it was
mostly teachers and they were weren't as
many as there are now and and they keep
crying about oh that what we're doing it
we we need to reduce so last year they
put in one time 7.5% and they call this
the property tax reduction
act along with that this committee sent
100 million back from the excess swept
money so we sent 126 million back for
the 2023 taxes to be reduced they were
not so again this is this is a kind of a
wasteful way of spending money that
doesn't really amount to anything it
doesn't help the town the contribution
is so minimal that um you know and
another figure I've asked for and maybe
you can find it is there was a time when
the towns didn't pay very much they were
paying at two and a half% while all
these other people were paying like five
and and and seven and eight and
nine when is the point when the employer
has contributed more money than the the
employees um that's I I have a chart
that can present that I know just from
from past testimony uh for for the
employee and the group one side it was
about 2007 was the crossing point where
the employer rate was greater than the
the member rate uh for police and fire
for most of the first 30 years of the
plan the member was paying more but for
about a 10-year period in the 80s the
employer rates were were were fairly
high for police fire but then they they
went back down in the '90s and then um
probably early 2000s they they crossed
over again so the employer piece was
less the law was changed I think in
either 2007 or 8 so that the employer
rate could never be lower than the
member rate and they move in lock step
if it ever got back down to that point
appreciate it thank you thank
you representative Griffin followed by
representative Maguire thank you Mr
chair uh thanks for taking the question
last last year we had a similar Bill to
this and we just we amended that bill to
put the money into the unfunded
liability so is that for your
calculating purposes is that a cleaner
calculation because it probably doesn't
get affected until the next year yeah
only from the acturial calculation if we
had an appropriation of x million when
the numbers are done for the year and
the actual RRS it up and sets the rate
you know they'd be basing it on that so
you know that would reduce the employer
contributions by a smaller amount over a
you know a 20-year period essentially
while that would be recognized so there'
be a oneye lag right yeah yeah the uh we
we're just we the board will be getting
and and certifying the fiscal 2627
employer contribution rates this coming
summer and and by the same same token
the municipality would get the benefit
more than one year right they continue
to get that benefit in terms of less
payment of the unfunded liability to to
the extent that the liability is less
than projected you know that lowers
employer rates and and this this bill
has structured funds the 7 and a half%
going forward as well so there's a
there's a savings on both sides that way
the 2022 was a onetime payment that was
a little weird because it was
we had to wait for the end of the fiscal
year true up the numbers and then you
know the state cut a check for a lumpsum
rather than on a monthly basis so that
that also caused some issues with uh
Revenue with some towns we weren't able
to to reconcile till quite late in the
year thank you represent Maguire thank
you Mr chairman thank you Marty for
coming um the difference you mentioned
between group one and teachers is that
mainly due to the lower number of group
one employees who get bested uh couple
of couple of factors there yeah they um
group as a whole group one employees
tend to retire those who go on to
retirement retire with fewer years you
you think teacher police and fire those
sort of Lifetime career type jobs it's
not unheard of to put in 25 30 years
certainly there's a lot of career state
employees who've put in that kind of
years but when you think about the
smaller towns there's a lot of CH so may
work there 5 years 10 years and that's
that that and the the pay differences
between say a Municipal Employee and a
teacher salary are the two reasons why
the rates are lower those those
demographic issues right if I can follow
up what um what fraction of group ones
work for the state versus
municipalities um we have uh there's
there's about 10 about 10,000 group one
state employees and group one as a whole
I'm trying to I we have about
24,500 total group one that's the
largest group it's about half of the
total population half okay when you when
you throw in state state employees with
a capital plus the group two state
employees State policing Corrections
membership did you have a question
representative Sweeny no
s so just a let the committee know where
this bill came from it was vacated uh
from Edna to us we held a public Hearing
in full Finance on the 29th of
January and we must act quickly we never
have to act quickly but well this has a
different deadline the most so I I guess
you're all set Marty with us I see the
prime sponsor here Mike do you have
or
and just uh state your name for the
record
please uh yes Mr chairman uh my name is
Mike Edgar I represent Hampton and uh
yes this is my bill I did speak on it on
the 29th of
January I'll try not to cry while I'm up
here as I'm talking about this this bill
uh and asking for money for the for the
towns the counties and others that
benefited from this this onetime payment
you know recently so um you
know the towns benefited from this the
counties benefited from it when we had
the uh the one year yeah they got they
actually got money and uh so I guess the
question is if in fact would be uh it
would be good to do this long term
and my good friend reny talked to me
about this for a long time and and
that's one of the reasons I brought it
back again um it does benefit the towns
and it benefits it in a more direct way
if you give them an actual payment
versus decreasing the uh unfunded
liability you know over a period of 10
20 years the difference that the way it
affects the towns themselves is amazing
and I think it's it's tough to judge how
what was going to happen or how it
happened with a a onee um dispersement
that you gave if it was longterm then
the towns and the counties could count
on it even some of the you know some of
these these groups you know they didn't
you for the one year because of the way
the budget's go and everything it didn't
decrease but uh I think that this is a
this is a good bill it's really could
benefit the towns cities counties and um
I know that there's a little bit of
there's some paperwork involved and I
know our people can handle it so is
there any questions for
me any
you is there anyone out there that would
like to speak to the bill seeing
none uh what would the division like to
do representative
wer did this last year it was labeled
property tax reduction Bill the same
75% it didn't make any difference even
when we included 100 million of reduced
swep payments so we spent six 126
million back to the towns did anybody
here see a tax reduction in
2023 that was with another 100 million
on top of it this is a waste as you hear
it gets complicated for what they do
with Dr it gets complicated for all
these things that they have to do a lot
of work a lot of paperwork and the
results are not there I would move in
expedient
second the motion's been made by
representative Wier and seconded by
representative
Maguire inexpedient to legislate are
there any comments questions before we
vote I I'll make it yeah sure thank so
um the other thing is we've already had
this bill last year right this was house
bill 50 I think identical and as you may
remember we made a big compromise on
that to switch it to 50 million for the
unfunded liability the house passed it
on the floor we put it in the budget the
Senate ripped it out so this year we
repurposed House Bill 436 for the exact
same purpose and uh that is now in the
Senate and when it comes to a hearing I
will go in for it um so so in my mind
this bill is is already still active
even though it's in a different form but
it but it essentially meets the same
purpose not in the same way so that's
why I think we it's inappropriate to
pass it now thank
you are there any more comments I guess
what I'd like to say is even though I do
support what this bill is looking for a
$27 million hit at this time when we
have probably over a hundred million
still on division one's plate is
something we need to consider
representative Maguire and I have a
retirement bill which I think has about
$50 million which is based on a
commission recommendation so um I will
be voting in support of the itl because
I don't believe we have the sufficient
this and that being said if the clerk is
ready please call the
role this is a motion to itl on House
Bill
1279 representative Maguire yes
representa GFF
yeses
yes
no um chair wer
chair so open the work session
on
[Music]
to
fin
January somebody here like to speak the
Secretary of
State
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm Secretary of State David
scanlin and I did do a little research
to kind of get some costs on uh uh on
what a New Hampshire Constitution would
look like I've got a prototype here I'm
around uh interestingly the cover is
actually the ratification copy of the
ratification document that that uh made
us a country so that's kind of neat but
anyway uh in terms of the cost of
printing that uh
5,000 copies is just over
$5,000 10,000 copies is about
$9,000 and 15,000 copies is uh right
around
$112,000 uh in contrast we print the the
larger Constitution that is made
available for school children uh in New
Hampshire and we print 5,000 of those uh
every year um and that at a cost of
about
$7,500 so uh those are are a little bit
um the um you know in terms if the
committee decides to move forward with
that in terms of uh
timing uh there are going to be a couple
it looks like there are going to be a
couple of constitutional questions on
the ballot
uh this fall and if they pass obviously
the text of the Constitution is going to
change accordingly so uh you might want
to consider that when uh uh you know if
you decide to move forward and make an
appropriation that you know if you do
decide to have some of those printed I
would suggest doing maybe
5,000 and then after the election's over
we can see if there's going to be any
textual changes to the Constitution and
then print a larger amount after
that questions for the secretary um sure
represent McGuire thank you so um thank
you for coming obviously
um I'm surprised the price difference
isn't that much right the other book is
more than twice that size and and you're
said this this one's a dollar and that
one's
a150 is that right yeah the um so using
5,000 because that's the number that uh
the the cost of the larger ones is about
7500 yeah and the cost of the smaller
one is just under Ju Just over 5,000
yeah so the larger ones are well that'
be about 50% more expensive um you know
I think a lot of the cost and I'm
speculating here I don't know this for
certain I think a lot of the cost is the
setup charges uh things like that and
then that is a nice glossy cover so that
that adds a little bit to the expense as
well
okay are there any additional questions
for the secretary seeing none thank you
sir
yeah I I have an amendment oh no you
does if you could see that the secretary
amendment
once everybody yeah once everybody has a
copy representative McGuire will discuss
his
Amendment
that's all right represent all right so
uh the amendment does two things right
first of all the timing so I agree with
um secretary of state that the
constitution because we passed that
slavery Constitutional Amendment it
seems very likely that that will change
the constitution in this November so
this amendment takes effect um in the
next budget basically July 1st
2025 so that we don't end up printing
ones that are going to be quickly
obsolete right so
um and so the idea is they can develop
it and it looks like he's already got it
I mean I was thinking over the spring
next year and then um print it starting
July 1 and put the money in his budget
and the other thing that this amendment
does um is
that and I don't oh yeah is that if
somebody wants like a box of them they
don't have to give it way for free they
can charge them for the costs right so I
don't think it's right for the state to
be subsidizing groups or whatever so so
this lets him charge the cost for for
the boxes that's
all are there questions for
representative Maguire concerning his OT
his
motion could could we change the date
make maybe make it an earlier date than
July because we're going to know in
November what the Constitution is going
to be that's true but I I wanted it the
money for it he can put it in his budget
put in his budget okay thank
you any further
questions are we happy with the Maguire
Amendment representative wer is going to
move that
right seconded by representative
Sweeney and seeing no further discussion
when the clerk is ready to please call
the rooll on
[Music]
to9
yes
yes yes
representative yes
chair chair Le
yes
n
all so the bill is amended motions
offered by representative Wier and
seconded by representative
Sweeney when the clerk is ready next
time I'll just do a show of hands on the
amendment save our clerk some
time um okay so did somebody make an oop
pass as amended motion wer and S and
S
okay uh representative Maguire yes
repres
yes
yes being um 90 the motion
minutes
yes
hit could I um yeah so um representative
Edwards has a bill I think it's
1583 that has both an HHS and a
Judiciary component they're hearing it
today at 2 o'l so if we can and maybe
this other one is not too not too
doesn't take too long the 150
maybe we could recess and join them uh
chairman
uni
I have am
22 but I don't think
it's
for me sen Bill 22 is the most
problematic bill
justs
right and I again it's two separate
things
together
of
the DAT that you're looking at February
23rd
RIS
I don't think they want my help on
this
yes
man there there's a chain like a like a
family chain and it goes from hoe zipple
to Maryann Dempsey uh to me and to your
point sir uh I think she and I are
probably second cousins
I've yet to find out how I'm related to
it
okay welcome to division one we'll move
on to
1355 which is uh relative to the New
Hampshire National Guard Recruitment and
reenlistment incentive
program this uh passed out of the house
on a Voice vote back
on February 1st and came out of the
committee um state and federal relations
20 to to zero so any one of you like to
and and again just introduce yourself
and if your name is really difficult to
spell Al though I believe the chair over
so
yeah that's in case get years hey Sir Mr
chair and committee members for the
record on Major General David mtis the
General New Hampshire National Guard
Department of military Affairs and
veteran services and I'm Warren Perry
I'm the deputy agent general for the
Department of military Affairs and
veteran services I'll keep this brief um
the biggest challenge to the Department
of Defense today is not China or Russia
it's our ability to maintain our all
volunteer Force how do we man it there's
two major levels levers assession
getting kids to join and retention
keeping them in uniform two years ago
you solved our sort of ass sessions
challenge where we offer $1,000 referral
bonus to anyone refer someone to join
the National Guard how do we take care
of retention those mid-career sergeants
right generally speaking there is a
federal retention bonus when there is
not we want to use state general funds
to apply to a state retention bonus for
our mid-career sergeants to keep them in
that's what this is about when we
testified at the federal labor uh
Committee hearing
we said we would live within our means
we are comfortable doing that within our
current
appropriation I don't want to mislead
you maybe two years from now we come
back to you for additional funds we'll
cross that bridge when we get there
right now we're comfortable with living
within our means figuring out what the
demand signal is how that budget goes
and then we'll reconsider a re-evaluate
at that point in time subject to your
questions that's all I have thank you
represent Maguire thank you Mr chairman
I have two questions first um why would
some members be eligible for a federal
bonus and some
wouldn't sir great question is super
complicated uh we have different
categories of service members you could
be a full-time active duty Guardsman we
call AGR active Guard Reserve you we
have it's also so called a title 32 dual
status technician where you're a federal
employee Monday to Friday and wear a
uniform then you drill a week in a month
and though by the way we have
traditional Guardsmen who drill a week
and a month and have 70% of our Force
you have that next thing you have is you
have Deployable units you have non-
Deployable units right you have
Deployable units like a high Mars
Battalion that just came back from the
Middle East a military police who just
came back from the Southwest border but
then we have like a Garrison unit like
the headquarters element that doesn't
deploy those different C classifications
and categories dictate who can and
cannot qualify for a federal retention
bonus so so at at the end of the day
units that are not in table of
organizational equipment units so
they're they're called table of
distribution allowances so they're just
kind of support folks that run the the
the state headquarters they're not
eligible Federal technicians who are
actively serving that that in that as a
federal employee and their dual status
in the guard are not eligible for
reinvestment bonuses so that's that's
generally the answer to your question is
it all right so just to follow up on
that is it is this a very small number
of the total force is that it or yes sir
I think it's like less than 200 people
would be eligible okay compared to like
uh 2800 gotcha okay thank you my my
other question was are are is the
National Guard still assisting the
Department of Corrections in the prisons
no we are not it was a 90-day mission
that ended last April we are not no oh I
see okay so they hired enough to
whatever they we we'll let we'll let
commissioner Hanks answer that question
all right thank you very
much represent s like to move this I
move a to
pass seconded by representative
huitt when the clerk is ready um ought
okay um
1 okay uh representative Maguire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Camrose yes uh clerk
votes I representative huitt yes
representative grassie
is not here um and then chair Wier yes
and then chair leean
eight
so I'm going to open the work session on
the next bill which is Senate Bill 252
2:30
so we'll open up uh senator Bill
252 sorry we're a little late had to
visit with our friends in division
3 this passed on a Voice vote back on
January
3D uh the division has already had one
work session on this bill back on the
16th and initially it passed out a
criminal justice 20 to
Z so someone here that would like to
speak to Senate Bill
252 yes
you take a seat and just identify
record my name is uh representative
David Muse I am from uh from Portsmouth
uh and I'm the deputy ranking member of
the criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee
um right now one of the things that uh
is being distributed to you is
essentially an overview of the bail Bill
compromise uh that uh we came to after
many many many uh work sessions um so
the the compromise itself is spread over
four bills uh s SP 252 is is one of the
four bills um and essentially what we're
trying to do is Achieve the legislative
objectives that you see uh at the top of
this sheet uh across four bills uh which
isn't terribly easy um
so while I think it's uh always best to
uh have all four bills open in front of
you um that can be a little bit taxing
uh and I thought it would be uh uh
useful to just put together a quick
summary uh like this it kind of shows
you
essentially uh what the different moving
parts are in the different
bills this particular Bill SB 252 uh
relative uh to release of a defendant
pending trial directing establishment of
electronic monitoring program for def
criminal defendants released on bail uh
and making an appropriation uh therefore
um is a bill that actually achieves I
think one of the main policy objectives
we've been trying to achieve uh in New
Hampshire for quite a while um it's
essentially creating a situation where
we're reducing the risk of a of a person
who uh has committed uh a a violent
serious uh felony level crime uh from
actually being uh inappropriately
released uh and then um uh potentially
reoffending while out on bail uh so what
this particular Bill does is IT
addresses those 12 felony level crimes
um it also allows the court or
magistrate we talked about magistrates
this morning to order preventive
detention uh for these or for other
crimes if it's determined by clear and
convincing EV evidence that release will
endanger the safety of that person or
the public uh so the bottom line is it's
not necessarily limited to these 12
felony level offenses similar to the
current statute uh there's a provision
in there that allows prevent preventive
detention um in the event that there's
clear and convincing evidence that this
person presents a danger to themselves
or others the other thing that it does
is it sets a 24-hour limit on the time
that a person can be held without a bail
hearing um over the course of many many
many public hearings and getting the
input of uh uh folks from the Judiciary
folks from the ACLU and and all kinds of
other stakeholders one of the things I
think that we learn consistently is that
there are definite issues with holding
people in jail uh for long periods of
time who haven't yet been convicted of a
crime um uh that's something that in a
lot of ways is aberant uh to our
Judicial System um so in addition to
setting the 24-hour limit um and and one
of the reasons we set the 24hour limit
is some of these bills that have come
before us have had limits of uh 72 hours
sometimes longer when you run into a
situation like that uh a person who may
have been accused of a crime and not
convicted stands a good chance to lose
their job they might lose their housing
uh they might lose their kids uh there
are a lot of consequences to being held
uh held in jail like that so the idea is
to make sure that uh no matter what
crime you're accused of you have a
hearing within 24 hours and the
magistrate part of the bill which is
something that we talked about this
morning is one of the things that allows
that to happen within that 24hour period
uh currently uh our judges don't work on
the weekends
uh and if we are going to have uh if we
are going to treat these crimes
differently one of the things that we
need to do is we need to have a
provision in there that essentially
allows people to have their cases heard
uh over the weekend in a timely
fashion uh the bill also uh requires
electronic monitoring uh for anybody
who's released under a protective order
so for instance this is an issue that
will come up um for instance in a
domestic violence situation a
misdemeanor domestic violence situation
um where the uh the offender and and the
victim sometimes may both want to have
the person released uh or the or the or
the victim may be concerned that the uh
uh that the accused offender may be you
know coming back for a second bout or
something like that with what what this
would require is something that isn't
part of our system now which would be a
24-hour Electric monitoring for people
accused of uh of crimes that are subject
to a protective
order um the bill also uh authorizes
courts to set cash bail amounts only at
a level uh that the person being charged
can meet so I think the issue here isn't
how much money uh we're we're making as
a state or not making as a state from
bail um the the real issue is do we hold
a person uh or do we release some
unpersonalized are if there are good
reasons to hold a person we hold the
person um that that does not change but
the fact that you have uh you you may be
Indigent you may be a low-income person
your your income uh once a decision has
been made that it's okay to release you
um your income really shouldn't play a
role in affecting that decision so
that's also part of the uh part of this
bill as
well um there there are also fiscal
Appropriations that are made in the bill
um there's a
$750,000 appropriation uh for the fiscal
year ending June 30th 2024 that's this
fiscal year uh for the State Police to
develop a a computerized system that
will finally allow uh the court system
database to actually uh communicate
effectively with law enforcement in the
field one of the things that was
identified in several of our hearings as
a as a significant issue for our police
departments was they really have almost
no way of knowing unless they were the
the the officers who arrested the person
before if a person that they're
arresting on another crime um is is a
person who is currently out on bail so
uh by creating this system that would
let an officer know right away if he's
arresting somebody who's actually uh
who's who's reoffended uh who's been out
on bail um it would also appropriate uh
$986,000 to the judicial branch uh to uh
uh I'm sorry uh let me see I think I
screwed that I mess messed that
up um uh and I'm just trying to think of
the I would have to look at the bill
look at the bill itself it looks like I
AG
is what happens when you put things
together
to I think these are these are separate
Appropriations so one is the Department
of Safety to implement their part of the
system the other is uh to the judicial
branch to uh Implement their part of the
system um but again this is what this
does is it finally would put law
enforcement officers in the field in a
position where they would actually have
the information that they need in order
determination so one of the things I
think you can see is that um where we
started on S sp250 2 and where we wound
up were different places and I think
that was um uh pretty common for all of
these bills one of the things that we
that I think we really wanted uh to try
to do um was to come to um number one I
think we wanted to come to a bipartisan
agreement that uh that addressed the
fundamental underlying issues uh that
cause our bail system periodically to
fail us from a public safety standpoint
but I think the the other thing that was
really important to us was making sure
that we did it in a way that didn't
violate people's civil liberties um you
know that uh and that uh that
essentially protected rights that I
think all of us would want to have if we
were ever in a situation where we were
unfairly um accused of one of these
crimes so I think that's one of the
things that we have with that I think we
had to balance from a a policy
perspective is it was important for us
to to sit there to listen to the data uh
and we got different pictures of the
data from different people with with
different points of view um but I think
the most important thing was to to
actually sit there and and listen hard
to what everybody had to say and and I
think one of the things that we came to
a realization of is that um there there
are there are issues with a system there
are ways for us to improve it from a
public safety perspective but there are
also some fundamental uh underlying
systemic problems um that make it more
that that actually increase the risk of
people who shouldn't be released of get
of getting released and and some of
those are with the way that we current
do currently do the bail commissioner
system um uh others have to do with the
fact that you know we have a situation
where we continually have um uh the same
people being arrested over and over for
minor crimes um and uh and and being
released and and I think well it's hard
to address every single issue you know
in in the context of even a compromise
like this one of the things that I think
we wanted to do is in a situation like
that where the underlying systemic issue
has a lot to do with homelessness has a
lot to do with drug abuse has a lot to
do with mental health problems is to you
know to put the state and and the people
of the state in a better position to
solve that problem going forward so um I
I think what we tried to do overall in
the compromise was to address the things
that we could address within the
criminal justice system and to try to
set some things up uh and for instance
the um uh HB 653 actually tries to set
things up so that issues like um
pre-trial services for people who are
homeless and who have drug abuse
problems and who have mental health
issues are things that are approached um
not just from a county level but maybe
more from a state level more from a a
systemic planning level uh and and I
think that's really kind of where we
tried to tried to get to so as you can
see we we had a lot on our plate we took
this extremely seriously and um and one
of the things I can't emphasize to you
enough is is how important it is to pass
this as a
package
um and with that I can take any
questions that you
have representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
coming um the way I look at Senate Bill
252 is it has three main parts that all
cost money all right and let's start
with one of them is the fact that you
can't use bail Commissioners for serious
crimes that means you need magistrates
they need to work on weekends etc etc or
judges do one is the electronic
monitoring of certain um accused while
they're out on bail right and one is
this database of sharing uh uh who's on
bail with with among law enforcement all
right so let's start with the easy one
first and that is the electronic
monitoring as far as I can tell the bill
contains no appropriation for that at
all um no nothing to buy the ankle
bracelets nothing for the people that
right okay all right we think it's right
all right so second question
so the bill
um asked I think it asked the Judiciary
to do this
monitoring and um but in reality as I
understand it it's the counties who have
uh control over uh defendants right so
they're either in county jail or they're
placed on bail and they can be monitored
by County
officers and
so it's and beyond that there are at
least one County straford County and
maybe others that already use ankle
bracelets and all already do this kind
of monitoring that the bill wants for
everybody do you know of is that correct
from your your knowledge yes yes okay so
um in my sort of back of the envelope
calculation I was told that that
straford County had 50 ankle
bracelets and there's roughly say 300
people on on bail at any time in
straford County but only 50 of them are
wearing ankle bracelets because those
are the serious cases and that they have
five officers dedicated to monitoring
and checking up on those 300 people and
so if if I sort of multiply the numbers
and say Well straford County might be 8%
9% or something of the total that would
mean we'd want roughly six 600 ankle
bracelets for the whole state does that
make sense MH okay so um but I'm I'm
thinking of changing this so that that
becomes a responsibility of the
counties and for 28a issues we add some
money in here to pay for the ankle
bracelets but they they counties are
presumably already monitoring they
already have the Personnel Etc so
therefore we wouldn't put extra money
for that we would just put money to buy
them equipment right so does that sort
of make sense to you it it makes sense
and I and I think it's kind of the
difference between criminal justice as a
policy committee and and this committee
uh you know with the with the U
responsibility to actually uh you know
manage the fiscal part of it um I I
think the the important thing not to
lose from a a policy perspective is that
this will give uh especially victims of
domestic violence uh and for people who
would be protected by protected or
protective orders a level of protection
that they do not have now uh so this
would actually be a significant
improvement from a public safety
perspective so this was one of the
things that we we we looked at really
hard when we were going through and and
and looking at this bill um because
there are there are there are going to
be situations and we we heard about them
time and time again where you will have
people who are under protective orders
who who have to be released and and I
think we've read about those incidents
time after time in the newspapers where
somebody who's you know been uh who is
out on a protective order goes back um
gets in contact with person they're
supposed to stay away from and and
sometimes violence uh violence as a
result so I don't think that that's an
acceptable outcome to anybody and I
think part of what we're attempting to
do with this is to to again kind of walk
the fine line between simply not taking
a person like that putting them in jail
and throwing them away you know locking
them up and throwing away the key
because that person could be the bread
winner in the household if that person
isn't able to work they may lose their
home you know there are all these other
things that that that we've heard about
so how do you increase Public Safety in
a in a situation like that and
monitoring is a solution that is you
said is already used in one County um
and is in widespread use for this
purpose across the country okay all
right so let's let's assume we we've got
monitoring sort of under control or you
know we have a we think we know what to
do there um let's go on to database so
this bill spends $1.7 million to between
the two Department Department of
Judiciary Department of Safety to to
create a database of essentially
everybody who's out on bail and and it
would be used by police officers when
they when they arrest somebody to say
you know I'm arresting you in ASA and
find out oh you're on bail in Manchester
right something like that is that that's
right that's right okay so I spoke to
some police officers and they told me
they already do this for domestic
violence cases maybe not all but but a
lot and they use a system they call
ncic are you familiar with that system
yes so is that essentially the same
thing but for just some
cases I think it's it's similar I I
think what we're talking about would
have wider scope and would involve more
offenses than NC than what I understand
yes it would more cases right yeah and
and I asked my the officer who told me
about it is there any reason why you
couldn't use
ncic for the for every case why
everybody was on bail couldn't you put
them in and they said I don't see why
not so do we really need so the question
is and maybe somebody behind you can
answer better do we really need to spend
this money or do we just need to somehow
use
ncic more thoroughly more more
extensively a lot of the a lot of the
conversations uh that took place around
you know what would happen on the back
end and hooking the systems up and
things of that nature um I think those
were between representative Roy um and
folks in the judicial branch there may
be someone in the judicial branch here
who might be able to answer some of
those questions okay all right well
we'll go on then so now the last one is
also quite expensive and that is you
want to say that you can't use bail
Commissioners for certain very serious
crimes do we have and and and we're not
sure um
we have the same problem with with 318
is 318 also has this list of crimes that
bail Commissioners can't be used on I I
assume it's the same list essentially
right right um but we yeah I'm not sure
we have accurate numbers yet as to how
many such cases there
are uh statewide right so um we're going
to need that to know whether that makes
sense but just just from your committee
standpoint this is quite an expensive
item because it it requires us to hire
these
magistrates um just for those particular
things and and we heard earlier and
maybe this is just anecdotal from from
um representative scitec who's a bail
commissioner that in his 23 years of
doing it no judge has ever changed his
bail condition
right so so is this really a case where
the bail
Commissioners are are making errors I
mean obviously they're human they're
going to make some errors but but so is
a judge right so
um is there is there a concept here that
there's
serious you know day after day kind of
Errors among the bail Commissioners or
is it or is this just you've had a bad
case once and twice you know something
like
that we have we've deal we have tried to
deal over the last three sessions uh
with the whole issues of issue of bail
Commissioners the training of bail
Commissioners the payment of bail bail
Commissioners um we've had a lot of
bills that have come before our
committee and and one of the things one
of my personal observations is that when
we get those bills we we tend to get
folks from the bail commissioner
All-Star team uh who who come and
testify and representative scitec is one
of them I mean these are people who are
dedicated public servants they work for
next to nothing they a lot of times
they're getting up at midnight to go to
a police station um they perform an an
incredible service for the State of New
Hampshire the issue is is they are
leaving uh some of them because they're
not being compensated adequately some
because they're just sort of Aging out
and it's time to go on to something else
and it's just a really really difficult
to recruit new people uh new people to
do this
so in the absence of that one one of the
other things you also have going on is
um the inconsistency of
training um so one of the things we were
surprised to hear in in the last session
was that after um the initial round of
bail reform um uh a lot of the bail
Commissioners who came to us had said
that they had never received any formal
training we also found out that the bail
commissioner handbook hadn't actually
been updated after that initial training
so it's it's something where we have
these people who perform this great
service for us they work virtually for
free um and we kind of expect this
little machine to sort of keep chugging
along and and I think one of the things
that we've realized um and it and it may
be through just a handful of of in
incidents like this but there have been
incidents where people were
Commissioners have released people um
who might not have been released by a
judge uh and and I think one of the
things that calls into question is the
qualifications for being a bail
commissioner are very different than the
qualifications for being a judge or a
magistrate and and I think what what
what I think uh it it comes down to is
the the offenses that are the most
serious crimes um should be heard by the
most quality ified people when it comes
to making a bail decision and I think
that's what this is about the problem is
if you go too far the other way and you
eliminate bail Commissioners altogether
you wind up with a number of hearings in
court that becomes totally unmanageable
for our judicial system without
significantly increasing the number of
Judges so one of the challenges for us
is how could we get to a better result
um within the bounds of our Constitution
and within the bounds of our leg legal
framework to protect Public Safety you
know how could we do that uh without
breaking the bank in terms of the the
number of hearings that would be
required and the number of Judges that
would be required to to sit in on those
hearings and public defenders to
represent people during those
hearings uh so magistrates 15
magistrates it seems like a lot it it
seems like a it seems like a like a big
investment but I I would say it's an
investment in a better in a
fundamentally better process I think
it's a process that establishes clear
guard rails for um the bill
Commissioners themselves they're going
to know what cases they can hear and
what cases they can't um uh it's going
to create a situation where where people
who haven't been convicted of crimes um
aren't going to languish away in jail uh
just because they've been accused of a
bad crime they're going to get a hearing
within 24 hours hours and a
determination will be made whether they
need to keep sitting in jail or whether
they can be released so I mean these are
this is sort of where it gets
complicated and I mean one of one of the
reasons why I think we we eventually
wound up coming together on this is I
think we all realized that there was no
way we could individually get everything
that we wanted to get out of this
process so I so I think part of it was
to try and get to a point where
um you know where we could we could
point to specific things in the bill and
say these specific things will
measurably improve um Public Safety in
the state and they're be and they're
supported by processes that are actually
workable you know that that's the thing
a lot of we we can make all kinds of
directives as a legislature um but I but
I think you know part of our
responsibility um isn't just to be the
folks who stand up on a you know stand
up on a Podium and and yell the loudest
I mean our our constituents depend on us
to actually work together to come up
with Solutions and and and good faith
Solutions and I think that's what we've
tried to do thank you um and I
understand that you want this whole
package but you know resources are
limited and
um it's it's possible that a a partial
solution will give you a good way toward
the toward you know solving problems
right so so you know we might be
inclined to to do some but not
everything that you want here and and in
particular you talked about making a
workable
solution I'm concerned
um we are definitely I think going to
give you the bail the the strengthening
of the bail commissioner system more
money definitely paid training all that
sort of stuff right and hopefully to get
build up the the the um the body of bail
Commissioners the problem with the
magistrates judges the magistrates
system you said you wanted something
sort of more effective and more workable
but but bail commissioners
visit and speak to in person the accused
in the arrested person in the police
station right so they get to see them
oneon-one
and and take the measure of those people
right
and we're never going to have enough
magistrates necessarily to cover the
entire state in such a way that people
the get together in person it seems to
me right and so well they maybe they're
going to do it on Zoom or something like
that you know but
it's there's an aspect you know maybe
the person's better trained but maybe
they're not as effective in that way so
it's something we have to think
about further
questions I have a
few so looking at the bill is amended um
by the house you did mention the
$750,000 uh for the State Police and
then the $986,000 for the judicial
branch data platform and electronic
sharing of individuals bail
conditions and I looked back at the
original um fiscal note and it mentioned
U the cost of the judges and Court
assistance four judges Court assistance
for for a price of $1.5
million um that is now I assume gone I
don't see that in the new
language
however the latest fiscal note that we
have the department of safety says that
the U Department anticipates their costs
will be significant and I'm not not sure
what that is leading to is that
significant millions of dollars hundreds
of thousands of dollars and then the
judicial branch and we do have a
representative here uh from the judicial
branch but the judicial branch says the
cost of hiring magistrates and again
this is the most updated uh fiscal note
says that will exceed $2 million so
there appears to be maybe Mr Hoffman or
Melissa can help me some disconnect over
all the different numbers
yes uh at representative McGuire's
request we've invited people from safety
um um eron here from the judicial branch
and someone from straford County to talk
about the electronic
monitoring um the original fiscal note
is now I think this bill was from last
year so that was on the bill was
introduced yeah the latest one I have it
says amended 116 so January but that's
almost last year uh or the re the
revised the revised one February this
year I think is most
believe yeah I have it revised amended
on the 16th and revised on the 23rd yeah
which has those statements from the
court and the department of safety so
cost that's correct it I don't know if
this is 100% relevant but in House Bill
two last year there was a bill that
included Appropriations for this the
system yeah and then the Senate amended
that came in at the end of the house
that's where those dollar amounts for
the Appropriations came from at the time
um at the Senate's requests we worked
with safety in the judicial branch to
come up with those numbers for the the
appropriation for the systems the $1.7
okay because when I get when I add up
all the numbers based on the um the bill
itself is amended plus the fiscal not
it's like $3.2
million so well we'll hear from the
judicial branch and Department of Safety
and others that try to square this
up all right are further questions for
representative
Muse representative
huitt
well part of the problem here is that
we're dealing with something that's
old uh for example the provision of
baale uh in the city of
lonia is made by a municipal
ordinance and
the people are arrested all the time and
they get brought to in in many cases
they get brought to
jail there are approximately at the
moment I think we have four or five
active people who are bail Commissioners
within the city of Leonia I haven't been
there for a while so I hav not sure but
when I was there uh we conduct I cond
conducted training sessions uh at least
three or four times a year for the bail
Commissioners and had individual
sessions with new bail
Commissioners because that's a difficult
job as we're all we're all finding out
here here and part of the problem here
is money and what we what we got here is
not only that we have AR spending enough
money we don't know how much we're
spending right and based on everything
I've been hearing for the last couple of
days uh we don't know how much we're
spending because we avoid it to the
greatest extent possible so if you want
if you want a a a a report on how much
money is being spent it's going to be
very difficult because number one a
large number of people who are arrested
brought to the local law enforcement
agency and sit around for a while until
a bail commissioner can be
produced uh or if it gets so Tak so long
that they can't find a bail commissioner
that the the local judge winds up trying
to de divide the
spoils
they the the the money the the people
are bailed and of course cash bail is
not a very popular thing not because not
because we only arrest poor people um
but because in addition to arresting
poor people we have we arrest people who
would have the money don't have it
available on hand and there is no
procedure for getting the money from
wherever the heck it is to the to the
police station these are they are all
kinds of crazy little problems that go
into this uh and hiring some judges and
some
magistrates not going to do you a bit of
good I'm sure the court system will find
many good things with them to do uh
but and and you can't you can't just
bring people in and then let them go
home that's the pro that's the situation
we have now now and what your problem is
representative news is that you can't
find all the problems because many of
them aren't
visible many of the problems are uh
invisible to to to everybody
except the individuals who are
involved because nobody wants to talk
about it either so I I I'm when we have
it when we have a work session on this
I'll I'll empty the room by by giving a
speech um but at the at the present time
what we're faced with is a
dilemma and the work your committee has
done is is is
outstanding uh and that and the
information that you've developed and
the IDE ideas that you have developed
need not be
destroyed uh because those are the
things that are ultimately going to
solve the problem but before you can
solve the problem you've got to identify
the
cause and know there
are I don't know I don't know how many
bail Commissioners there are in the in
the state 95 95 bail Commissioners in
the state you know how much they get
paid it depends on on where you are
because in some places like lonia there
is a municipal ordinance I haven't read
the ordinance in many years but I don't
think it says anything about money uh
and money is not available all the time
to you know to to furnish the the system
with the wherewithal to keep the thing
going and and and likewise people are
arrested uh in the middle of the night
tend not to have a lot of money
available right and that's that's that's
too bad and it's a bad thing that they
know they're going they're going to stay
overnight but it ain't their fault and
it ain't our
fault we got to we got to figure out how
how to solve the problem
and what youve done of views is you have
you have cast cast a light on the on the
overall problem and now it's if the if
the legislature is going to work on it
it's going to have to work on it a piece
at a time all these you know two new
judges well you know what you going to
do with two new two new uh Superior
Court style judges uh on on bail
cases and and it goes on and on the
police the the counties most in except
for
Hillsboro
um
the over that that that area uh and
bringham is not an awful lot of County
activity involved in the in the bail
system and
so I I want I just want to say that you
you've done Yan's
Duty and and the committee can't be
can't be accused of having done anything
wrong or about dropping the ball because
they're not they're not armed with all
the necessary
information and finding the information
is
difficult further questions
representative evil I have a just a
simple question what is the status of
s249 and HB 653 because you said this is
a
combination of four bills and I wondered
where the other two bills
were I believe those passed on consent
on the 3 of H January and are back in
the hands of the Senate
okay well one of them is the Senate
Bill speech 249 I mean maybe you know
the
answer 653 I think was on consent as
well yeah okay Senate Bill 249 was
heavily mod modified in the house and um
did not come to our well we waved it
actually um and so because it didn't
have a a anything in the fiscal note um
but possibly that was a mistake I don't
know um but uh so it's back in the
Senate um as an amended bill and I don't
think they've acted on it and I'm not
one
we'll make that decision shortly I hope
thank
[Laughter]
you we still got two more don't yeah
we'll have to move this long are there
are there further questions for
representative use seeing none I'd like
to call the representative from the
could
be
pay hello again Erin krian for the
judicial
branch so obviously you heard there were
some questions and uh so to your
knowledge as far as Senate Bill
252 what's the impact on the judicial
branch because we've seen a couple
different numbers here whether there
judges included in that
magistrat U the court along with the
Department of Safety said there was some
significant impact I think the court
said $2 million so what can you tell us
to help
us thank you for that question there's
there are a few things that are
addressed very directly in this
particular Bill and then there are some
that are sort of spread across the
package and what what I didn't want to
do when I Was preparing some of these
fiscal notes is failed to note that it
would be connected so for example the
magistrate appropriation is not in this
uh but there's extensive reference to
magistrates so I noted the cost of
magistrates but that is not two million
for each of these bills it's 2.2 million
across the board to add 15
magistrates um the the major cost that
are
discussed here uh are the building of
this electronic bail data platform and
the cost of electronic monitoring uh the
cost of electronic monitoring I don't
know and I really appreciate rep McGuire
having looked into it with the counties
because I think they are in the best
position to tell you what their current
costs are so that you can try to
extrapolate what the cost for that would
be for the State uh it's not something
we we currently handle so there would
certainly be a large cost if we're
responsible but it's very difficult to
estimate without doing that work right
now what that cost would be uh for the
electronic bail data uh interface we did
actually bid that with a a vendor uh at
the time that these questions were asked
back with hb2 as Mr Hoffman was
mentioning uh and this is the the sort
of two-year contract price to which has
the very very high front end building
the system cost and then the annual
maintenance cost after that I believe
dropped to a little bit under 300,000
which is about the cost of transitioning
a case type to P from a paper to
electronic system uh you know New
Hampshire like many states does not have
a fully electronic uh case management
system many case types are still done in
paper people mail their filings to the
court or come in person and file them in
paper and that's true for a number of
our criminal cases as well a number of
the criminal cases that occur in the
circuit courts are done in paper so bail
Commissioners are going to the um
different police stations sometimes the
jails and they are filling out a bail
form in paper and that is brought to the
court uh where if it's Superior Court it
might be entered on an electronic docket
where you can see it if it's Circuit
Court there's a notation that a bail
order exists but you can't see it and
you don't know what it says uh so that
is
an issue that we still have a highly as
many states do highly paper-based system
for a large number of cases and I think
that was something that the committee uh
the policy committee noted impeded
communication on an individual who's
committing a series of crimes and
impeded the ability to get information
on their current bail conditions so the
so The Upfront cost again you said
continuing it would be $300,000 a year
what's the initial impact the high the
the highest impact is the 700,000 for
first year setup and then this is a
2-year contract so it has uh about
700,000 for year 1 about 300,000 every
year
thereafter um so that that's a part of
why the cost is so high for this this
front end because we don't have the
system we'll have to create an interface
where a bail commissioner will be
instead of writing things on a paper
electronically entering into this
interface all of the data so that it
lives there in real time so where did
the $986,000 figure come from in the
bill this is the the vendor that we bid
it from okay yes and if we if we so that
number can be lower than in the bill the
986 I don't know if we can get a lower
Bill bid we can certainly put it to RFP
and see if a lower bid's available for
Department of Safety no this one the 986
for uh sharing of individual Bill
condition
status right but it's together with that
no it's separate n 750 for state police
986 for judicial my understanding is
that's for the whole system is is both
of those this system involves two
different areas the police and one's the
judicial branch one's the judicial
branch one's the state police but it's
for the SI the same system yes it it is
I think originally when uh this was
first discussed it it was only put to
the Department of Safety what their cost
would be but without the information
entered by bail Commissioners and the
courts it just wouldn't be complete and
so it was we were asked to give an
estimate of what it would be for us to
also be feeding into the system and so
the combined cost setup costs is about
1.7 million I I don't know what the
annual costs after that for the um
Department of Safety are but for the
judicial branch they're under 300,000 a
year after
that
um
surek can you or maybe somebody behind
answer my question about the NCC
database this gentlemen I
can thank you so ncic is a a federally
administered database I I don't know
what our ability is to to add Fields
but the what's contemplated is to make a
system that is exactly like our existing
bail order form but it is being filled
out electronically so instead of living
in paper it's going to live in an
electronic system I don't know whether
there's a way to compel the federal
system to to take a form like that or to
process that as part of their
information it's just not something I've
into further
questions seeing none but don't go
anywhere I think um Rett McGuire I did
attempt to get some numbers for you uh
could I ask if you could uh just repeat
your question so I make sure that I'm
giving you the correct numbers so how
many for the for the um cases that are
being taken away from the bail
Commissioners how many such cases are
there every year uh based on 2021 data
that
is400
okay and the I think the average number
of people that see a bail commissioner
in one way or the other is actually
exceeds 10,000 I think I thought it was
a little less than that it's actually
probably over 10,000 as I looked into it
all right so my math would say 1,400
cases 15 magistrates each one would do a
100 a year or two a week so that's not
very much work for a magistrate yeah I I
think if that were the only thing that
they were doing that would that would be
a very good point that may be something
that the committee uh considered because
I was looking I think it might be
249 that actually lays out more yes I
think it is 249 that also gives them the
ability to issue search warrants hold a
hold arraignments and other preliminary
hearings and I think the thought with
that was that there's a potential cost
saving because a magistrate would be
less than a a Judicial officer to
perform some of those functions uh in a
large Court arraignments are a full day
calendar every day has to be kind of
heard by a Judicial officer so I I think
you're right if that were the only thing
that magistrates were doing in addition
to training bail Commissioners and some
of the other responsibilities they've
been assigned in this package you you
could have an inefficiency there but I
think they their answer to that and of
course they probably shouldn't be
speaking for them was to add some other
duties as well for a
magistrate representa Sweeney thank you
Mr chairman thank you again for being
here not to throw a question to you with
you might not have the number for right
now but for the existing judges that we
do have obviously we don't have
magistrates what is their weekly
workload or case load that they deal
with that's a great question um I'd love
to send you if you wouldn't mind uh we
had a we had a weighted case load study
done by the national Center for Cas uh
state courts which was really good we
knew we were busy but we didn't know how
to quantify it and they helpfully did um
and what they did basically is separate
there's a number of timelines in our
statutes where uh the legislatur
determine that the court has to do
something in a certain period of time
and if we meet all of those deadlines
everything else goes into the second
bucket which is drastically
underresourced um and I think we
determined we were about six or seven uh
judges short to meet the the goals of
that bucket and I know that there are
many legislators who have taken that up
and are working on that so I I don't
want to belabor that point um but at the
moment we're we're a little short on
judges thank you if I if I may Mr just
to add a comment I think there might be
a healthy balance here with the the case
load that we can expect 1400 cases for
the magistrates there might be a formula
we can figure out what the proper number
is based on that case load a year and
Burg down by a week as to what existing
judicial officers have to deal with
so and rep Sweeney may I may I burden
You by also responding to a question I
think you asked me earlier that I now
also ran down about the 848 number
that's our total estimated annual unpaid
so it's not that number decreased by an
expect expectation that half of that
would be repaid that's the number that's
left over assuming that we're able to
pay everyone else it's it's more like
1.6 1.7 in total bail commissioner fees
in a year that's what we're expecting we
need to pay to compensate all of the
bill Commissioners who have an Indigent
defendant appear before
them thank you very much now if we could
have someone from the Department of
there yes the young lady that's been
there
is it okay we have three oh absolutely
two chairs more and if you could all
introduce yourselves if you have a
difficult last name spell it for our
Clerk and yes please use the mic yes my
name is Jennifer Hackett I am the
administrator 3 for the J1 program of
New Hampshire State
Police my name is Jen Jessica mcfaden
that's Mac fad Zen MC fadson I'm the
police I'm Jeff Leong I am the J1
technical lead for New Hampshire State
Police so obviously you heard we had
some questions and one that comes to
mind is that your department thought
there'd be some significant impact of
this legislation so I'd kind of like to
boil it down to see significant in money
or what it's all yours sure I believe
two areas that we would like to address
first is two questions that were brought
up during the discussion around the NCC
system itself and specifically around
the cost let's start with the NCC system
itself um I'm going to kick it over to
Jessica to clarify that because the
system the way that's our spot system
the way that it set up now will not
allow us to retain that information and
disseminate that information through NCC
as it stands right now and there's some
regulations on why that can't happen and
I'll let Jess go into further detail
detail on that just to clarify that for
you thank you Jen um again when we talk
about the ncic system it contains 15
different persons files and the one that
you were referencing is actually
referred to as the protection order file
that file was designed by the FBI and
the entry criteria that were allowed to
use to put information into that file is
only for those persons that have had a
protection order issued against them so
the only bail condition we can enter
into that file in the database would be
those criminal bail orders that are
related to domestic violence related
offenses where the bail order becomes a
domestic violence restraining order so
any other bail orders that are issued
for any other crimes that are not DV
related would not meet the criteria
mandated by the FBI for us to enter into
that protection order file and the other
14 persons files that we have none of
them have cr criteria that allow for
entry of anything related to bail
conditions
either thank you thank you for coming
that's very useful
so how do we know somebody gets arrested
in
Manchester isn't the system there so
that they know this guy jumped bail in
Atlanta or something like that no no the
way the system is designed to work in
order to put somebody into any of the
those 15 files each file has its own
specific criteria so in your example if
we're talking about an individual that
jumped bail in Atlanta in order for them
to be entered into NCC they would have
to meet one of the criteria for those 15
files most likely in this case if we
were going to see them in the database
then someone in Atlanta would have had
to have issued a warrant for them and
then they would go into the wanted
person file the fact that they're on
bail by itself would not meet crit IIA
for any of the files once they violate
bail the agency that issued bail could
get a warrant and then that warrant
could be entered into the system where
it's available Nationwide I see so this
system is to find out they're on bail
now but they're still in in U compliance
with that bail right because the you
know the court case hasn't come up yet
or something like that but that's
relevant to us because if you're already
on bail and now you commit another crime
maybe your bail should be revoked is
that the idea yes that would be the idea
gotcha okay thank
you further
questions represented grassy no
Griffin cell
no all right um that question of cost
yes so I'd just like to address one
specific area around cost when we were
first approached and was speaking with
the courts about this particular
initiative there were two different
avenues that we could pursue the most
coste effective and the most um the the
the plan that would give us the most um
accessibility excuse me to the
information is by having the judicial
branch um enhance their existing system
by doing that J1 or ncic the only thing
that we are doing is we're building a
hot file via NCC for that information to
travel from the court system into NCC to
allow law enforcement to access that if
we follow that pathway the cost for us
does drop in many ways and probably
pretty significantly building a hot file
is a little less cost prohibited so it
probably would only cost the state uh
New Hampshire State Police somewhere in
the range of
$200,000 to build that particular hot
file because of the fact that we're not
building the forms in which the agencies
or the individuals would enter this
information so it does change that a
little bit um as far as the cost for
that so you go down from 750 which the
bill highlighted from the state police
down to roughly 200 then correct okay
thank you y that's very
helpful one more
question I feel like Columbo here all
right
um so let's let's talk let's explore how
useful this system would be right so
we're we we're thinking about a case
where somebody goes out on bail they
enter it into the
system and later they get arrested for
something
else but currently we don't know because
it's somewhere else right it's not in
both if both are in Manchester right now
we would know it presumably right but if
one of them's in nashille and one of
them's in Manchester we wouldn't so um
So currently this second this person is
arrested the second time is bailed out a
second time um whereas with this system
they won't be bailed out the second time
yes all right so the question
is how many times does it occur that
such a person currently commits a third
crime okay because this system will not
prevent the first
two it will only prevent the third one
and the fourth one and the fifth one
like that do we know how many times that
happens what I can say is that I
specifically don't know the stats on how
how often that happens Jess and Jeff I'm
not sure if whether or not either of you
have that information either but what I
would say is we can also look at it from
this perspective of not necessarily how
many
but how law enforcement is able to react
to that person that they're now having
contact with because with that
additional information they will be able
to see what the conditions are of that
person's bail so if they pull that
person over and that person is violating
any of those conditions they will then
know how to respond and without that
information there's a kind of a gaping
hole on exactly how to respond to that
but the exact numbers of how frequent
that happens I don't have that
information right now just from their
license plate or you mean so the query
would be correct me if I'm wrong the
query would be spawned off of a license
plate query yes okay yeah now this is
important for me because my my town had
an officer killed in a situation like
this right they pulled over somebody and
and got shot and they didn't know that
this
person was wanted or whatever yeah okay
I understand thank
you any further questions for folks from
the Department of Safety seeing none
thank you very much thank
you is there anyone else that would like
to speak and i' encourage you to be
quick we're way behind some of it's our
fault
but and if you could state your name
please for the record my name is Albert
Sher I'm a professor of law at UNH
School of Law I'm also a police Police
Commissioner elected Police Commissioner
in
Portsmouth um I've been working uh I've
been involved in the criminal legal
system in New Hampshire for the last 43
years um so for lack of better putting
it I've been around um I I also have
been involved in uh the bail issues ever
since the original bail Reform Act
sponsored by uh Senator felus which uh I
authored that for Senator felus uh and
I've been involved
uh in talking endlessly with members of
the House criminal justice Public Safety
Committee so this is something that
matters to me both as a police
commissioner as a law professor and just
as a resident of New Hampshire there's a
a a bunch of pieces of questions that
been asked that I think I can add some
additional light to so I apologize for
Dr jumping around but uh part of the
part of the problem in terms of the the
the data and the money uh in uh s SP 252
it starts to solve a a bigger systemic
problem the court system uh for reasons
of money and history uh does not have a
data collection system it has a case
management system so the court system uh
not intentionally by any means on their
part but just the way things are they
can't tell you how many people who had
bail set in two different cases and a
third time get involved they can't give
you that number not that they don't want
to but they just can't because we need
to spend you know separate issue for
this Committee in the future sometime
millions of dollars to put in place a
data collection system from the for the
court system so uh that's the
overarching concern this money in SV 252
is to create a smaller
system uh at least financially to cure
this problem represented by a case I
wrote about uh in uh an oped piece in
the union leader uh several months ago
an individual was arrested and charged
with attempted first-degree assault in
hillsbor in Manchester uh he uh went in
front of a judge had a bail Hearing in
front of a judge and because it was a
relatively weak case uh the judge set
personal recognizance bail with some
conditions um that was in early July I
believe in later July he was arrested uh
in uh man Nashua for some misdemeanors
including uh refusing to leave a
McDonald's as I recall uh and um that
bail
hearing the arraignment on those
misdemeanor charges was Poston till late
August uh in late August he was arrested
a third time on uh a bunch of additional
misdemeanors in
nashaa um at the bail Hearing in in late
August early
September the prosecutor who was arguing
bail on that
case didn't mention a word about him
being out on personal recognizance bail
on the first attempted first-degree
assault it never come up likely she
didn't know about
it uh and the prior Manchester CH the
Manchester charges that happen in Late
July those didn't come up either nor did
the prosecutor uh on the original
attempted first-degree assault
cases apparently notied that these two
subsequent sets of arrests had occurred
in Manchester and Nashua uh so that
prosecutor uh did not file a motion to
revoke Veil on the attempted
first-degree assault the reason I bring
this case up is in uh within a week of
that bail hearing where the person was
again released on PR bail uh he
allegedly uh killed an individual in
Manchester
originally as uh you know as as things
happen some in the news media went
ballistic and said this is why we need
to change the bail system well the truth
was we didn't there were plenty of
Provisions in the bail statute as it was
to deal with this guy the first time he
was arrested on misdemeanors after the
original felony bail was set but nobody
knew about it this problem was the
communication of the bail status of that
individual once his bail was Set uh
person PR bail was set in the attempted
first-degree murder apparently nobody
nobody who was paying was Prosecuting
the the first set of additional
misdemeanor or the second set of
additional Meers knew about it so they
didn't raise it he clearly would have
been held by any judge uh that's why
this system is
important um because it it it tries to
create it will create a system where
when somebody is put on bail it
instantly goes into a system and
everybody in the state of New Hampshire
knows about it every prosecutor every
police officer knows about and for that
matter the way the system's going to be
set up every defense lawyer knows about
it too um that's what this is
about uh to to cure that problem um it's
it feels expensive in the short term in
the setup money but uh it's uh boy is it
worth
it um you know
arguably I don't think I'm overstating
it there will be one less person who is
now
deceased with this system and know let's
not go to the philosophical debate of
how how much it's worth a system to do
that um so that's uh that's what that's
all about and that's why the money's
there significant startup cost no doubt
about that um uh in terms of um the
magistrate judges uh I I I you know I
work I was at almost every single
hearing that house criminal justice
Public Safety held from September to
November uh you know three months of
hearings and every stakeholder that we
could scare up had an opportunity to
testify and what we heard over and over
again particularly from the Manchester
Police Department was we don't want to
keep going in front of bail
Commissioners they keep screwing things
up we want these people on these serious
crimes to go in front of
judges and that was a major impetus for
the magistrate system and we as we
started to think about it I apologize
for this um as we started to think about
it as a committee started to think about
it uh and we're talking about it you
know there as uh the representative from
the court system testified there's
there's a lot of additional benefits to
having these magistrate judges that go
beyond sitting as judges on uh as more
substantial uh uh judges there's a
requirement that they be lawyers uh um
they can they can uh do search warrants
uh they can do arraignments you know it
it helps manage the Court's overwhelming
case load at this point particularly at
the circuit court level or the district
court level where uh the legislature has
sent has gotten rid of what's called
felonies first so probable cause
hearings and felonies if they were going
to occur had been occurring in Superior
Court they're now be they weren't having
probable course cause hearings up there
they're now going back they've been in
circuit court now since January first a
lot more case load for for district
court judges so the the the Magistrate
Judge is judges are not just a one-off
to get rid of those damn bail
Commissioners I I really encourage you
not to think about it that way it really
stabilizes in important ways a lot about
the court system which has been
overwhelmed by a host of changes over
the last several years
um electronic monitoring uh I point out
that the cost that straford county is is
incurring for electronic monitoring is
for they have a pre-trial Services
Program because they're uh for these
purposes they're a wealthy County
because they house a lot of federal
inmates and make a lot of money off of
that as chesher county is now doing uh
and they're starting to have a pre-trial
Services Program so but the people who
are getting electronic monitoring
straford County go well
beyond those who have had a protective
order placed on them this legislation
only has it only accounts for electronic
monitoring for people who have a
protective order against them it's a
very narrowly tailored thing so uh just
be cautious about extrapolating from
straber county numbers uh Statewide you
know I because I think it's a small
subset if any of those stford County
cases were protective order cases which
is what the only thing that this uh uh
249 is it 249 we're talking
about 250 uh yeah 252 excuse me that
that's all that
252 uh talks about um let me I apologize
uh
for uh just as a backdrop to what the uh
house criminal justice Public Safety
understood there's some data coming out
of hearings uh that I and others
attended several years ago involving the
office of of Cost Containment which is
irrelevant to this discussion except out
of that hearing came the information
from uh the criminal justice system uh
both from then chief justice Netto and
from the director of the public defender
program that somewhere between 25% 25
and 35% of all misdemeanors and felonies
for which Council was appointed were
either the finding was either not guilty
or they were completely
dismissed so this issue of bail is you
know making sure we don't incarcerate
people too many people we don't ER in
the direction of over incarcerating
pre-trial is really significant when you
contemplate that say 20 25% of those
people who might be held might be held
uh and are later found not guilty or
their case dismissed I think that's an
important context
um I'm done I apologize for taking so
long presenta Maguire thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Professor for
coming um I want to push back slightly
on your first example of the fellow who
was um arraigned on on attempted murder
and then later attemped first degree
assault what whatever it was okay and
then later this and or that and so on um
the way I understand the Court's
database is it's called Odyssey and it's
essentially a filing cabinet with a
folder for each person and in the folder
is scanned copies of all the paper that
has come in on this person right So
eventually scanned right so so when they
were put on bail in the first place by
the first judge that piece of paper
would get scanned it would be in the
folder in theory it would would be
unclear at what time that's right so so
either in your in your example was it
was the time too narrow or was it error
on the part of the prosecutor in the
second case just to not look in the
folder and not read every piece of paper
that was on the folder you see what I
mean oh I understand what I understand
what you're asking and you know um I
I've been involved in the criminal
justice system in New Hampshire
forever and uh I've seen every possible
kind of error made except for the next
new one that's made I mean it really you
know so uh you know I was I was a public
defender for 13 years um and so you know
back when I was a public defender I was
more than prone to say well it's the
damn Prosecutor's fault you know uh but
or you know every so often if I could
get away with it without pissing the
judge off it's the damn judge's fault
you never you never said it was the
clerk's fall cuz then you're in trouble
uh we don't know it could have been any
of those things it could have been the
information didn't get in the system it
could have been an overworked prosecutor
in those offices who didn't have time to
look at that it could be a lazy
prosecutor uh it could be some a
prosecutor who's got a lot of experience
and knows that well it's never worth
it's not worth checking cuz nothing ever
comes of it you know we it's not going
to it's not going to make make the
system perfect because you know the good
thing and the bad thing about the
criminal justice system is we still
depend on people um and so you know it's
still going to be the case no matter how
accessible and instantly accessible it
is emphasis on instantly accessible it
is people are still going to screw up
but boy I don't think what happened in
Manchester or the case I described would
have happened if this system were in
place thank
you
seeing no further questions thank you
very
much any all right we have one more and
I remind everyone we try to be I'll be
quick I promise I'm straford count okay
so we try to focus on the uh Financial
issues here in finance and not so much
policy but some policy information is
good I'm I'm really not here to to talk
about the merits of the bill at all but
just simply to provide you the financial
information which we're pass which we
passing out now um I I do want to say
that we've been doing pre-trial we could
have your name the record sorry my name
is Raymond Bower b w r uh and I'm the
County Administrator but I also um
originated the pre-trial program uh we
currently monitor 571 people in the
community and 80 incarcerated in the
house of correction so give you an idea
it's about six or seven to one in the
community uh 73 of those
people are on electronic monitoring for
a whole variety of reasons and the
professor's correct that uh only a
portion of which uh is for domestic
violence related issues the nice part
about about electronic monitoring for
domestic violence related issues is you
can put zones into the uh electronic
monitoring and those zones um if there's
a violation of that zone um it will be
reported but you're right we do have a
whole
pre-trial uh segment obviously to watch
571 people and it's for a whole variety
of Criminal Justice uh related issues um
everything from uh habitual offender
information to uh child support
information to everything and the goal
is to keep people out of jail that don't
need to be there and it's a significant
uh 175 people that we monitor are people
that are mentally ill um so that we
don't uh flood our nothing's to me more
sinful than to incarcerate someone who's
accused of a crime primarily because
they're mentally ill so um the last page
the first two pages of the handout
really are the every time someone is
brought into the jail before they uh and
the commissioner has decided to set some
form of conditions that doesn't allow
them to be released immediately meaning
they're waiting for
arraignment I have an employee that goes
in and interviews the specific person
face tace and then takes time to check
on the information that that person
provides obviously they can't check
every single thing but they check the
pertinent things uh so that this can
then be presented to the judge at the
time of arraignment and the judge can
use that information to make a more
informed Veil determination which could
very well include them being ordered to
our
program the second document that I have
we I've passed out is actually a new
assessment form U the first one is is
called the um color Colorado risk
assessment form the second one is one
that's been piloted
probably a million cases now across the
United States um
for more actually more inclined to weed
out violent offenders and offenders who
have uh skipped from previous uh Court
obligations
and it's also a relatively simple form
um and it's ad it's recommended by the
national pre-trial assessment
Association
so in the last page is um we currently
have 70 as of March 1st 77 people on
electronic monitoring last year we had
234 uh total people costs um are listed
there uh we charge $100 per week however
if no one if no one is eliminated from
the program if they can't afford it we
allow them to uh work in our community
work program which uh if they work for
eight hours which could be anything I'll
give you an example now we're helping
Special Olympics that's our adopted
charity so we're uh getting ready for
the Winnie dip this coming weekend and
they can come and help us set up for the
wiy dip they're supervised by
correctional officers and they can earn
$120 credit off of this bill for working
one eight hour day so you know our goal
is not to tremendously burden the
taxpayer U uh straford County taxpayer
in in this um a lot of what's been
focused on is providing information to
the Department of Safety uh indicating
State Police State Police have almost no
involvement in this program so I simply
ask that if that is something that this
committee is seriously considering that
you give a lot more than the department
of safety access to this information
uh obviously would be of tremendous
value to us although I'd like to think
that we rarely miss someone who's out on
a previous uh pre-trial situation
especially if they're from straford
County because we interview every single
person um and I'd be happy to answer any
questions repres quick represent Maguire
thank you so do you think you're
presumably uh this is costing you
roughly uh $500 a case it looks like if
you're spending 118,000 for 234
cases um do you feel like doing this is
much cheaper than somebody in jail is
that the idea oh much cheaper I mean
that this $500 a case somebody could be
on an electronic monitoring for months
right um and and although I will tell is
jail like a 100 a day 100 a week not not
in my jail okay we're we're $79.89 and
that includes depre apption of the
building and everything so it's not just
an operating cost per day it per day
yeah I um and we I know that for a fact
because we as it was pointed out we do
board federal inmates and we need to
quantify those costs in order to uh get
a rate set by the feds for the inmates
that we board for them so I'm positive
of that
number any further questions see none
wait I have a really represent what's
the the uh lifespan of an electric
monitoring unit um really it's
indefinite um as long as the battery's
charged and that's part of the
requirement you know is is that the the
person keeps the battery
charged you know they just need to plug
themselves in basically it's like your
phone you need to plug yourself in
obviously the most con a lot of times
there's curfew set um so they can plug
they can plug themselves in during their
Reg curfew
time and if you don't have a house we'll
we'll find you a place to live we'll
provide you one if that's the only
reason you're incarcerated is you don't
have a reliable residence to go to we
run a um we have about 30 beds in for
men and women obviously separately um
that uh we provide and a number of the
people that we house there are are
people that have no access to permanent
housing um which is one of the
requirements of the program certainly we
need to know where they
are all right well thank you very much
and before you go representative Muse I
have a quick
question thank you thanks a good
job repres grassy would not allowing me
to do anything less I assure you he
keeps a tight leash on all of us here so
so hopefully this will be a a quick
question with a quick answer so in 252
it makes reference for instance on page
two the decision of bail shall be made
by a magistrate within 24 hours of
arrest that's on line seven and 8 but
there's no Financial note for that but
but in the document which is helpful you
gave us on Senate Bill 249 it talks
about the 15 magistrates so if 249
doesn't pass and how does 252
work it's a good
question I'm just kind of curious why
maybe they weren't combined so you'd
have the magistrates at 252 has in it as
reference for bail are covered in cost
so it just seems like we're going to
have to try to Mel them together or well
part of the uh part of the compromise
process is trusting the Judgment of your
chair in terms of how things should be
arranged in the bills that are part of
the compromise um I think things are are
the way they are uh because um in his
judgment and I don't want to speak for
him but but I think in his judgment he
thought it was the most effective way to
move forward uh with the bill so all
right well thank you that's all I have
well thank you all for oh I'm sorry just
please we're going to hold you to two
minutes representative Maguire is not
going to ask a question either
so so if you could see that's
unfortunate but my name is Pat suin I'm
the executive director for the New
Hampshire Association of chiefs of
police I'm retired police chief from
gtown um currently still employed in law
enforcement for over 42 years now
um with that I'd like to thank chairman
Lesman and committee members for
entertaining me uh a couple of things
this bill reform is a huge priority for
the Chiefs Association and we support
this bill
wholeheartedly um it surgically
reinstates the 13 most egregious
offenses um for bail um and that we
feel that the money it's obviously an
issue but at what point do we
place money above Public Safety and we
can debate all day long about the
gentleman in Manchester and the uh
release
Etc but we need to protect the
public that should be about two minutes
I'll take any questions if you have them
well there's like 30 seconds left so
represent you have a question okay no
amendments not yet thank
you thank you all very much uh we'll
close the work session on
252 I don't believe we're going to make
a decision today but we will have
another work session which will be
calendar does does anyone need a quick
five minute
break uh represent grassy absolutely
see did a good job you did a good
why
so you said that 249 was completely
revamped but are the 15 magistrates
in9 yes but in a very weird way and also
all right so we'll call the work
session back
together so we have House Bill 1178
relative to an employees unused earned
time this came out of the committee
labor committee 1010 with no
recommendation or unanimous
recommendation anyway it was uh on the
house
floor uh as amended and the vote was 199
to
179 and then the bill as amended passed
on a Voice vote on the 24th of
February um representative Cahill if you
introduce yourself for our committee
please good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Michael kahill I
represent the towns of newfields and New
Market in Rockingham
10 and uh this is not a new this is not
a new idea this uh legislation we've
talked about it before but there are a
couple of differences which I think are
relevant um as in the document I I I
provided uh a key difference was that
the uh the bill last year HB 74 had a
language that it would be applied if the
employee left in good standing that is
they gave notice work their notice
perhaps helped train the replacement you
know any things that people like to do
out of courtesy and it works good for
the employer and the employee but I
removed that because that was an
impediment for for some and the other
body so uh it is an issue where you know
it does happen I provided some some
information about how frequently uh
claims involving uh um unused and unpaid
vacation turn up in wage claims it
impacts uh if you if you lay someone off
or they and they you don't them their U
week or two vacation uh the first thing
they do is collect unemployment which
affects the the unemployment trust fund
we'd like to protect that in the House
labor
committee so you know there are some
impacts and plus the the idea the person
who had earned this vacation time and
now it vanishes through no fault of
their own uh they don't have you know if
they go and file for unemployment it may
take a week or two to get that to happen
and then they they're lucky if they get
60% of their pay so it's a significant
event the person may may begin to run up
their credit card bills may fall behind
on the rent this is It's a societal
impact and basically I I think that many
employers would do this without being
told by the
legislature but it's unfortunate that
some won't and so that is this this
really is for those people that that
don't do it and that leave people you
know with you know a few hundred dollars
that would have made a difference at the
end of their employment and now it's now
it's gone it's not there and I've I've
given you examples of that happening uh
the scenario where the companies changed
hands and the people stayed on working
for the new employer but they each lost
several hundred in vacation time that
just vanished uh another example I think
as proud of serus is a a person was laid
off without notice which is how it
usually happens and she had I think it
was
$2,300 in earned vacation that
disappeared and this was because uh she
was not able to request the vacation
time in two weeks with two weeks advance
notice which if you're laid off with no
notice it's you can't it's impossible
it's a catch 22 so we talked about the
policy issue which the labor committee
uh did not agree on but the uh the the
the house certainly did as it has
several times in the past now uh I also
gave you document about uh I found this
in the New Hampshire Business Review
yesterday looking beyond the pink slips
of layoffs and that talks about how
layoffs uh also negatively impact the
company those who stay behind may not be
the best that that are staying behind
they're they're not there to the people
who left aren't there to help restore
the business so layoffs are bad for
business they're bad for employees
really to be avoided but again when you
lay someone off and you say well I I
don't have to pay your vacation time
that's like another kick in the pants
and let's not let's not keep doing that
uh I do want to be straight with you uh
in the f note and and my my good friend
David J brought this to my attention
there is there was an error in the
amended version of the bill that passed
and my intent is to when we go to the
other body ask them please and thank you
to fix it I do have a a a short phrase
that will fix it but the uh in in an
effort to to make to appease the people
who sometimes have like seasonal workers
and lay them on for this winter they're
not going to pave roads or whatever it
is and then they there was reluctance to
pay them the vacation time when the
intent is to have them come back when
you know spring is over you know spring
is back so in effort to do that I
inserted some language uh about the uh
layoff with no reasonable Assurance of
the employee returning however there was
an error there because uh it leaves the
impression that if you lay someone if
you fire someone for cause or they quit
they also get the vacation pay and that
was not my intent uh unfortunately when
you're thinking about something and
trying to fix it you sort of Miss the
forest for the trees so uh upon getting
this to the other body I will ask uh
colleagues in the other in that other
smaller chamber to fix that I'll provide
the language uh which uh it was straight
away just clear that right up I didn't
want to EMB burden you with that or I
can I me take any
questions are
questions uh representative evil where
is the error in the bill itself um okay
um not withstanding RSA
275 43 Roman
5 18 it looks I don't have the lines
here
sorry all right so if an employee is
separated from an employer as defined in
RSA 275 col 35a which by the way is new
created in this bill uh because the
employer's business closed changed
ownership or what it says there is
because their employment ended with no
reasonable Assurance of the employee
being able to return to set employee
this is where the fix would be uh we
cross out strike out because their
employment ended and replace that with
due to a layoff so it will say due to a
Assurance are there further
questions I do have a couple of my own
now looking at your the document you
gave us uh dated
today you have five bullet points has
sold the business closed the business
has laid off what if someone
quits they don't get they don't get
their vacation pay or they don't have to
under the law an employer can do it many
many many will but they don't have to
under the
law and just a nine Financial question I
guess how did you determine 15 was a
reasonable cut off because I've heard
from smaller businesses that are in the
20 to 25 range and they're a little
upset they're someone's propos they be
told how to manage there right uh the 15
was was provided by the Department of
Labor as a number that small businesses
are familiar with for a variety of other
things so 15 is not a new number to to
watch out for um and previously I did
have I did have a very nice letter uh
from the uh anasua Chamber of Commerce I
think it was where they were supportive
of the concept and I think largely
because of that
threshold I I know Mr Burk you would
like it to be 50 or 100 employees but
that's not reasonable and I don't know
if small businesses actually offer paid
time off mine does yours I'm good for
you yeah you're doing the right thing
yeah and I have less than 15 employees
but that's beside the point are they we
ask represent cells yeah I just like to
point out that
uh to me
um if uh first of all it's a good thing
that this doesn't occur that often you
by by by your own numbers right very but
it does occur um the thing is uh if a
company chooses to use that policy and
not pay vacation for somebody who's been
terminated that I I think that's a bad
policy for them and
um but yet it's their policy so the
employee took that job knowing that that
was the policy
of the company so again I think it's bad
policy I don't think any company should
be doing it uh it will not help them to
retain employees or to hire employees so
I think that t the issue takes care of
itself and for that reason I wouldn't
think that this was
necessary um thank you for your comments
I understand you know that you
appreciate your situation I I want to
add that the effective date is January 2
January 1 2025 so it gives people a bit
as hands to adjust their policies and
again you know is it happens often
enough to where it CAU my attention it
never happened to me but uh if it did
you my representative would have heard
about it and they would have said well
there's nothing we can do and that's not
a good enough
answer
frankly further question represent
grassy oh just just a comment and and in
relation to representative gr Bell's Pro
um I was in a situation where um we had
a layoff because of covid we acred our
vacation time on January 1st people who
took their vacation time before covid
got their vacations people who took
their vacation time after Co didn't get
paid for any vacation time it just ended
we didn't get our vacation our vacations
were four years you so you've been there
and done that bill last year I well it
yep thank you
representative
representative EO I just want to clarify
there's no state or Municipal impact
from this bill or um previously uh last
last year Charlie commissioner Arling
house appeared before Labor I I've
invited him to come down here and talk
to finance but he appeared in labor and
he said that the cost to the state would
be di
Minimus uh then it doesn't happen and if
it did it wouldn't be big and I have
some uh I have some U supporters from
the municipal Association and I believe
there is a there's a again because of
the the the error making the recent
Amendment uh the university had some
concerns about this but that that was
not the intent of the bill and I had uh
been in contact with Miss proventure
previously before the amendment and she
had indicated that they had no
objections at that time I just have to
fix this or ask our friends in the
Senate to fix
it
Melissa um in your packet there is an
amended fiscal impact so the 2 million
is not um with the bill as
amended the statute that is amended in
this is not applicable to the state so
it doesn't impact legislative branch
executive branch or judicial branch the
municipal Association said there's no
impact to them the um university system
did say there was an impact to them but
I believe it will be reduced if the
sponsor Amendment go through because
basically the um impact was due to
employees who were let go for misconduct
so if the amendment goes through that
number would be
reduced and representative K you said
you'd bring that Amendment forward in
the Senate I think that's the best place
yes or we as my clerk reminded we can do
it here but
yeah I I would be in favor of that I
don't like the idea of passing on
mistakes to we never we never have so
why start why start
now all right so uh you can work with
representative Maguire and grassy to
bring forward an amendment to straighten
this out please I'll be happy to all
right you'll
see some notice in the future of our
final work session on your bill thank
yeah okay finally we have House Bill
1307 providing a supplemental
appropriation for members of the
retirement
system oh oh I'm sorry I'm
than record my name is Dave I'm senior
vice president public policy with the
business industry
Association almost never before this
are in all past iterations of this bill
we have been opposed
for the reason you stated C that these
design should be the employer that makes
decision not State over the summer and
uh fall uh represent kill and I worked
with each other and I said perhaps you
might want to consider a very narrow
proposal which would
um benefit those employees who received
AC crov vacation time but never had the
opportunity to use it and it was
completely out of their hands so we
settled up a layoff with no reasonable
chance of
beinged a business closure or a business
sale if the new owner of the business
was not recognizing that and that's
that's it um even that the Bia did not
support the bill however we did not
oppose and I tried to
explain how I thought this would be fair
for employ no never have the opportunity
take and it
would impact certain businesses
certainly but when you look at the
incidence of of layoffs business
closures it's a
address microphone oh sorry I thought I
had sorry do I need to start from the
beginning no
you're um the 15 uh employees is is a is
a somewhat arbitrary number and the
state could choose 15 25 50 is the
number that's often used for for federal
employment
regulations the the 15 is not uncommon
in the state though for uh
anti-discrimination uh statutes that
businesses have to comply the number is
generally 15 employees or more so I
think that's what the number that was
settled upon but it's it's it it is
somewhat arbitrary um I did want to
point out because uh representative
kahill and I did have a
conversation about what passed on the
house floor and he was right the um
the wording starting on line 17 and
continuing through line 19 does not
reflect what our conversation and
general agreement was there's another
area that that I'll be bringing up in
the Senate I don't expect this committee
to take it up because I understand
you're not a policy committee but on
line um starting on line 26 it says in L
of payment for unused paid time off an
employee uh may agree in writing that
they're unused used paid time off can be
carried forward and transferred to the
subsequent employer our belief is that
shouldn't be the employees decision that
should be the employer the the seller of
the business and the new buyer and in
cases where the new buyer doesn't
recognize the time then that should be
paid to the employee but the employee in
our our uh belief is should not have the
um latitude to say they want their pay
now regardless of what the new employer
says but uh I'll again I'll be dealing
with that on the Senate side if this
Bill gets over thank you Mr chair happy
to answer any questions represent grassy
yeah just a question on that on on line
20 uh 26 or you said there it says in
Lee of payment for unused time an
employee described may agree it doesn't
say that they're the one that asking for
but that they may agree to have it so if
their employers asked them if they were
willing to do that they may agree to do
it but they don't necessarily they're
not requesting it it's the employer who
them I agree with you and if they don't
want it they can get their money right
then and there that that makes it less
egregious yeah that I guess that would
essentially be saying the the employer
says you know we're divesting oursel of
this business and and we'll just pay for
any acred time and not leave it up to it
doesn't become a part of the but he said
as part of the sale I'm transferring it
over with your benefits right in intact
and he said sure I'll take that it's a
so representative grassy and Maguire
you'll make sure that works right good
all right we sometimes do do a little
policy here if we think we're making
things better but often we mess it up
but we'll we'll try we'll try to make it
yeah exactly yeah I think we'll be okay
I I can't imagine uh any messing up that
could possibly occur not on this not out
of here no
any
or he'll bring an amendment to fix it so
all right well thank you very much so
now we'll move to House Bill
1307 and I won't read it all over again
1307 and please state your name for the
record
please
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
Arthur bodri it's spelled b a u d y i Am
the President of the New Hampshire State
permanent firefighters retirement
Association I'm a retired captain from
the Manchester fire department and a
past Trustee of the New Hampshire
retirement system for 13 years I am here
today in support of House Bill 1307
which would Grant a stien to retirees
who have been injured in the line of
duty this group of individuals that um
that didn't want to retire they had to
retire due to their injury sustain
retirees have received a call retirees
have received one Cola since July 1st
2010 it was a 1 and a half% cost of
living increase based on the member's
retirement C at
$50,000 over the last decade the cost of
living based B on a CPI has gone up
approximately 29. 33% while col is
granted to group two police and
firefighters over the same time period
were
1.5% over the last 20 years the cost of
living has gone up approximately 64.5 3%
while col is granted to group two police
and fire over the same time period were
12.25% and 15% respectively that is over
52% of a pensioner's buying power that
has been eliminated due to inflation and
the lack of adequate cers in 2022 the
$500 stien granted uh went predominantly
to group one out of the $ 11.6 million
fiscal note group one received $10.75
million over 92% of the 11.6 million
went to group one over the 23, 267
eligible recipients there were only 498
Group Two Fire receiving the stien last
year the Senate changed a bill that
allowed for group two uh Cola benefits
to include group one and change the
eligibility of the stien to a members
earning less than
$30,000 again those changes eliminated a
large number of group two members the
average pension for a group two
firefighter is approximately
$45,000 remember group two does not
receive Social Security social security
has given its members an 88.7% increase
in 2023 and 3.2% this year unfortunately
group two police and fire did not
receive so don't receive Social Security
under the windfall act in 1984 if a
group two member were to be eligible for
Social Security their benefits would be
reduced by 40% at minimum and as much as
90% depending on their pension
predominantly the New Hampshire
retirement system is the group two
members uh is what group two members
rely on for their retirement income very
simple math shows that the members that
a matter of time without Coler
adjustment pensioners will be forced on
some kind of Social Services because
their pensions will be devoured by
inflation Most states provide a retire
their retirees with a cost delivering
adjustment the state of Maine for
example who came to testify at the
request of the denial committee offers a
3% Coler to their retirees manchest uh
Massachusetts offers an ad hoc Cola
based on a CPI of up to 500 5% applied
on the first
$133,000 Vermont offers an automatic
Cola based on a CPI up to 5% compounded
granted a reasonable Cola granting a
reasonable Cola for group two retirees
will greatly reduce the impact inflation
has had on them over the last two
decades the stien offer in House Bill
1307 is nowhere near what the retiree
should have received but is a step in
the right direction I you please support
your disabled workers and vote in favor
of House Bill
1307 um I have uh I got a text from uh
representative Damon she would have been
here but she was down in um uh education
and then she had a meeting and she
thought that uh representative Maguire
was going to come in uh to present it uh
for Edna but obviously that didn't
happen
so yeah
so I'll take any questions little
history on the bill it did pass out of
Edna 20 to zero and passed on the house
floor in a Voice vote back on the 22nd
of
February
questions representative
Sweeney no I assume Marty's
here
yeah I you want to break from questions
right I'd rather ask Mar a question okay
I guess there are no questions for you
must have done a good job oh hope so
thank you very much oh there is a
question well I just wondered you were
reading something would you like to
submit that for the record sure the
it thank you very much uh Marty I guess
there is a question for
you and Marty if you could just identify
yourself for the record please um Marty
Carin represent representing NH HRS I
don't have anything to say on this bill
but I'd be glad to answer any questions
anyone has I can so um Marty I I spoke
to representative Carol Maguire about
this and she said that it was to correct
an error an oversight that happened
essentially two years ago when we gave a
$500 um supplemental uh allowance to um
retirees who had been retired 20 years
or more
and that and that it was sort of an
oversight because disabled
retirees often don't make it to 20 years
but they wanted to give the this $500 to
that group but the way I'm reading this
is is it possible that there is disabled
employees who receive that 500 but would
also receive this 500 yeah under the
bill as written that that is true um I
think the original uh impetus for the
bill last year um there was a $500
payment that was ultimately included in
House Bill 2 I forget the the original
bill number for it and it had a require
had three requirements I had to be
retired by 71 of 18 uh had to have a
pension of under 40,000 and had to have
had at least 20 years of service that is
language that was uh used in a couple of
other colas there was in a years of
service requ is onetime payments uh in
past year not all of the $500 payments
have had that
requirement um so there was a
constituent a representative Damon in my
understanding from speaking with her
that had was disabled on the job you
know with 19 or so years of service and
didn't receive that uh the bill as
written came in would Grant $500 to all
accidental uh disability retirement uh
retirees or Ben beneficiaries receiving
that benefit uh who were retired prior
to 71 of 18 the benefit is under 50 um
and there's no years required for that
so it it is it is a SL so there could be
if you do an overlay there certainly are
probably some people who became dis
disabled later in their careers after 20
years I don't I don't have a number for
that um but the total population for
this as written is about $ 800 so
$400,000 um the the fiscal note is still
accurate
yeah no that's it
thank so Marty 802 people are disabled
out there
receiving yeah and um this is uh
accidental disability so that's the
statutory term that means job related
there are other there probably a few
other hundred or couple thousand people
who are retired under what's called
Ordinary disability that's non-job
related you know they got a disease or
you know fell off their roof or
something not related to work um and are
getting a benefit it's a different
structure the this bill only covers The
Accidental the folks injured on the
job represent McGuire does that include
PTSD types um that is um part of that
can be a diagnos the law was changed a
couple years ago and we've had a a small
number that that was the only Factor
usually there are a number of factors
that they're qualified under for
disability U we did did a presentation
for the there's a statutory committee on
PTSD last summer I don't have the
details of that at my fingertips but um
it was a it was a fairly limited number
we haven't seen an uptick in those cases
over the last five years since the law
changed or
anything further
questions the division have a pleasure
of what they would like to do with the
bill
car told me to move out the path you
better do you better do what she says
thought anyway have to have a little
humor right it's seconded by
representative grassy is there any are
there any further questions this is
house built
ready
okay so the motion is ought to pass on
House Bill
1307 uh representative Maguire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeny yes
representa
yes
with that we'll see you all tomorrow on
the other side of the
us
that